foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
alone
hello
chat
[Music]
hello
I think that's our hello emote is
Alexander it just makes sense doesn't it
this makes perfect sense
hello
[Music]
are you there
holy chat God damn
I don't want it that big [ __ ]
Trey thanks for the nine months baby I
appreciate you dude how are you
as an Elden Lord too what a stud
it's like way too much shadow on the
screen right I don't know I kind of like
it now
I kind of like it
they don't show the damn emotes man
[Music]
whatever we try to fix this every time
and it's doesn't do anything and it
breaks
look it already broke
already broke
son of
all right guys so
foreign
I took about a week break and I think it
was for good reason don't you
[Music]
if you hear if you were here for the
last streams
or honestly the last stream that we did
you know why I I took a bit of a break
that [ __ ] hurt my soul
it really did
it was kind of nuts
it was kind of insane like it was just
way too much
Melania while drunk okay if I have a
better build I can beat Melania in not
six hours
right
don't you think
probably
I don't know
I'm not drunk yet although I have been
drinking whiskey
that has been what I have been doing but
I am not drunk yet I promise
oh yeah you'll see me in a second I'm
yeah okay
hi
so also we're in a I'm in the middle of
a move I'm moving in less than a week
somewhere else so if I disappear for a
few days just know that's where I am
moving to a new place that's exciting
I'm very excited but I got my
I got my whiskey
[Music]
just kind of sipping on that that's way
too much chat yet again let's go up here
let's just do like this I think that'll
be good
sounds like something a drunk person
would say
Maybe
what whiskey I don't know
this whiskey that we had
yay new apartment
it's definitely Jack Daniels by the way
it's just Jack Daniels I've always had
Jack Daniels uh also
there's this
that we got
haven't had one of these since College
shot glass with it
as well
so
I don't know what like it's gonna entail
for me to take a shot
of Fireball
but y'all let me know and uh I guess
we'll do it
I just wanted to celebrate a hundred
thousand subscribers today with you guys
while I play Elden ring to the best of
my capability
I'm gonna call this guy
100k
[Music]
beat Elden ring before puking okay well
that's a good challenge but what what's
the uh like what are we
what it what's gotta happen for me to
take a shot like y'all got to figure
that out
2023 it's not even the game of the year
anymore week dude true it's actually not
because we're not
Riot exactly
did Joy get a hundred thousand tummy
rubs Joy's gotten so many tummy rubs
that she like you know it it probably
hurts her tummy at this point
are you guys thinking one shot before
every boss
I'm skipping
she want me to just take a shot now
what do you all want me to do because
I'm literally gonna go get uchigatanas
I'm gonna go get
serpent Hunter I'm gonna level that up
all the way and we're just gonna Bonk
everything
we're just gonna do big Bonk like the
speed Runners one shot every minute so
this will be like a five minute stream
you guys know I don't drink right like
barely ever like this is like the extent
that I'll do once a month is just like
half a glass of like straight Jack
Daniels
and just sip on it for like an hour
yeah just do you want to start it off
I literally haven't had Fireball since
College
I actually haven't I'm not kidding do I
have to fill this whole [ __ ] up look at
this thing
this thing is huge this is the biggest
shot I've ever seen in my life
look at that
do I really have to fill this whole
thing up
half
I ate
a few hours ago
the Cap's On I'm already drunk
every Rune Arc acquired that's actually
pretty rare that's not a bad idea
bro
this whole look at that
it's huge
that shot glass is tiny as [ __ ] I'm from
Denmark dude
it's huge man
[ __ ]
you guys kidding me
I don't even know if I can shoot all
that all right cheers
[ __ ] it
oh my God it's cinnamon
[ __ ]
wow I forgot how much cinnamon it is God
damn
it literally what it says cinnamon
whiskey that's what it is
dumbass
all right let's go
gamer time
that was pretty good
dude [ __ ] oh my God it hurt
man
uh just get a drink at your own pace
yeah I kind of just wanted to play Elden
ring uh while I drink
and then you know like if you guys like
coaxed me enough to take a shot then I
just will
you know what I mean
feeling young again I am young and I'm
in my Prime Esther okay
obviously
I'm in my literal Prime right now
I had no stamina bro
I'm triggered
wait
all right
that's fine I was you know it's a speed
run we just want to get out of there you
know I totally meant to do that
100 percent
let's go
it's totally meant to do that
do you think Miyazaki drinks when he's
not making a soulsborne I find it
extremely hard to believe that Miyazaki
and all the developers don't drink and
get insanely high on something when
they're coming up with their games
like all right we need to put a boss
here all right shots
everybody
and then they all get around a table and
just come up with [ __ ]
or they just get stoned
and then they're like okay Miyazaki
we've done
swamps
in all of our games do you really want
to know their swamp and he's like yes I
want to make it an entire continent
of scarlet rot
let's go
you know
no it's not the double enemy stream I'm
just drinking and playing Elden ring
today we're just big chilling
you're sure that's how they do it same
I think
honestly I wouldn't be surprised if that
were like factual
definitely factual also if you want the
double enemy stream we got to get the
500 members and we're at 284 that's not
even remotely [ __ ] close
so you know what to do what type of
build you're gonna do I want to do
serpent Hunter's strength build that's
what I want to do so I'm going to do it
this is what I want
Elden drink you guys like the title
I think it's funny
not click bait
gone wrong
because it probably will go wrong
what kind of drinks you having so I have
Fireball and I'm just sipping on Whiskey
as well
should we have a shot counter you guys
want shot counter cold
shots
one
okay can it be this big
like we good with this right here
about that
let's just go like this
there you go that'll be fine
it definitely won't get in the double
digits so I have to move it over right
I just don't drink
just don't do it
what type of punishments dude I don't
know I'm just gonna let you guys be like
Jake you need to take a shot for that
and I'll probably just be like true you
know what I mean
what up Logan what up Ludwig
use all the worst Epic no I just wanted
to play Elder ring today with my
favorite build okay
put it over your face I'm sure it'll get
over there soon
it'll get over there
I think the gone wrong is gonna be very
accurate so do I
alcoholic Jake origin story this is
where it all starts for me chat
I'm gonna get canceled after this uh
after the stream what do you think about
that
'll be fun
apparently it happens to everybody so
let's just do it
we're here for the oh oh like I was also
thinking like maybe I should do a q a
um but I was like you guys ask me
questions all the time like every stream
is a q a
but I could make it like an official q a
if you want like I will I'll go full on
total truth with you
shut up Honda Accord
have you heard you're not on Twitch so
you won't be canceled
which is weird isn't it
I bequeath
it is a trend to get canceled so if I
just want to like be trendy then I can
get canceled
I don't know what would I don't think
there's anything that I've ever done in
my life where I could get canceled I'm
like the lamest person on the planet
I just play video games and record video
games for for YouTube that's literally
my whole life
so
I don't know what I'm getting canceled
over but
must be sick
maybe it's my takes on like certain
animes or something I don't know
I I've always had a feeling the anime
Community would cancel me
looking forward to Melania dude I love
Melania I think she's great
she's the best like a literal Mommy
you know what I mean
let's see who cancels who exactly
oh God since my friend showed me Ronnie
h word I can't do her Quest again
anymore
do you guys think it's weird how horny
the Elden ring Community got when the
game came out
like dude people got super ultra horny
and I think it's just because they
experienced a good game for the first
time and like forever
it's like wow I can't even take how good
this is
and they just like made a bunch of porn
yeah it wasn't just Ronnie by the way
it was [ __ ] everywhere it was like
hard to not see
it's still better than the gentian
community
yeah
I don't know anything about ginshin to
be honest I heard it's like a scam
like uh
you [ __ ] uh you know what I mean
oh man
uh there's gonna be a lot of that by the
way I'm sorry
yeah it's like gotcha
you got to spend a lot of money to get
get good which is dumb
you know how much I've spent on Eldon
ring
sixty dollars
in a year
because that's how much the [ __ ] game
costs
never painted anymore never spent a
penny more dude
all the against your community is down
bad yeah don't they make all their
characters like you know what I mean
like hot
I don't know
I find it hard to find a cartoon hot
you know I mean but a lot I'm saying you
know what I mean a lot because I'm like
a little tipsy already
sorry
I guess a cartoon you can just make like
whatever you want out of it I guess
that's cool
but
yeah
who knows
do you think torrent is related to an
ancestor's spirit I think torrent's more
related to like a goat or something
yeah where's the more got porn drips
where is it
not like I go looking for it or anything
this is gonna be bad chat
[Laughter]
everybody never mind
let me just stop talking about naked
cartoons you're right Trey that's a good
point
through
with those dongers do you mean daggers
it's out there trust me how do you know
that
how do you know that
I want the other Uchi
this will carry me all the way to the
serpent Hunter
is there a Lorax dimension of the
spectral steeds
yeah dude you you give it a whistle and
you win
you just you get it
you get the you get the horse
all right can we finally discuss this
I've asked this so many times on stream
and I've never gotten to a complete
consensus because I don't know why but
the radon video I made like a year ago
not a year ago like nine ten months ago
like one of my first videos that really
blew up it's like my most successful
video
it got a it got an influx of like a
bunch of views like today and I was like
what the [ __ ]
um someone was like why do you say
Leonard like that
and I said Leonard and I still think
it's Leonard
like I find it hard to believe in a
world like Eldon ring that radon
star Scourge radon named his [ __ ]
horse Leonard
I think it's Leonard like King Leonidas
Leonard
I
thing like that
you know
I get so many comments there's this like
Leonard
it's Leonard
I'm gonna start calling them lying hard
in the videos and just make people even
more upset
I'm not native English yeah yeah
I feel you there neither am I
if you guys did if I wasn't English what
do you guys think I would be like what
from what a tree
just like [ __ ]
Swedish or something I don't know
dude this stream's gonna be real oh [ __ ]
Sweden why
why do you say that
I said that too
like if you're not from the US where do
you think I'd be from
Norway dude I want to be Norwegian so
bad
I'm I'm down bad to be Norwegian
you guys think I can beat Morgan like
this
should probably upgrade right something
like that
penny for the fjords
German yeah
my la like I am German that's like what
I'm mostly from
there's more outside America
no
America
is the only place that exists ever
oh tarnished
in search of the Eldon ring
tarnish
in search of the Elder ring I'm not
taking a shot yet if I die I will how
about that
the Whiskey's getting me Tipsy chat
why do you want to be Norwegian I don't
know I just think I would love it there
I have to go visit first
do it
can I take like a half
okay shut up Margaret
you were
here
that's bad isn't it
that's really bad
I don't do a lot of damage
I'm noticing right now
what
input reading
you see that input reading you read my
inputs
as soon as I [ __ ] healed he started
running
why is it so dark
okay that's bad
you gonna do the thingy
I deserve that I didn't even look at my
health bar man [ __ ] all right here we go
wine okay not every death but one for
the boss okay
one time
it's like gonna be a heavy or something
uh well that was a big pour okay
smog
why is it so it's because it's night
time thank you for that information
that's very helpful I just met like why
is it nighttime right now you know what
I
mean
all right
cheers
tapping on the table
yep
School
oh God
oh
how does it feel man 100k
um
I cried I'll tell you that
I'm kind of a cried baby [ __ ] though
it happened on Christmas day I was
hanging out with my family and I saw it
I was like holy [ __ ]
I cried a little bit
dude
dude Mark it's so annoying I can see why
a lot of people quit the game with him
nice
wish I could cry
you can man
crying's nice
feels good
okay
okay
this is [ __ ] hard well
I'm only two shots in too
Warrior blood must truly what
input reading
input reading
this is hard and it shouldn't be
I thought he was gonna do some [ __ ]
look at that
foolished
no no no no no I dude I am a lightweight
that's just facts
you should have some Gin with that L
Logan
don't bro
watch I go upgrade my Uchi one [ __ ]
time and he's dead
you got the shackle yeah this is a
normal playthrough I got the shackle
I'm not gonna use it though
just to make you in particular mad
okay I didn't think that would hit me
Mythic water after every three shots
what's water
what are you talking about
this is bad I'm such a lightweight too
holy [ __ ]
this is bad
okay didn't do the thing I want him to
stagger I want to thrust him with my
sword you know what I mean
that was cheeky
come on
that hurts
your daddy is destroying you
that's chill that's chill
ing nah you won't reach me way too far
away
I should just stripe those
no cap
foreign
okay
no
okay we did it
uh maybe
dude Margate is annoying man
foreign
no
this fight's been going for someone come
on
I can do it I can do this
that's just like so many attacks man
oh Poise regeneration
yeah
okay I'm not hitting him enough
consecutively right
jump yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
put these that's not fair at all dude
at all all right
Maggie says no
I shouldn't have this too
Jack Daniels by the way Margaret's
precise role in Elder ring is to tell
you to go away and come back when you're
ready
I'm I am ready though I've leveled up
zero times and upgraded zero times as
well
that was a test
[ __ ] you
right
say
poo poo poo Okay Caleb did you get what
you wanted there
poo poo poo
did you get did you get what you wanted
Kayden
Caleb
I'm fine
like imagine if I had an upgrade
just imagine it because I don't have one
you have a [ __ ] tail
okay
at least I don't have to take a shot for
every death
I'd be dead
what is he doing
I can see why no one in Margaret's
family loves him
I see it like I get it you know
it's literally in the Lord too
almost died there almost died
Thou Art of passing skill Warrior blood
must truly run thy vain how do you dodge
that [ __ ] attack
okay buddy
what the [ __ ]
Gucci's bleed right
power poop pants
we did it
[Music]
thanks Archies what up bro
like that
you get what you wanted
no I don't input read me
[ __ ] you
how do you dodge that attack I just
don't see it I don't see the opportunity
he did
that's one
that's one
and can you guys imagine some people
completely so over got so triggered on
that boss that they never beat him
oh
forgive me my personal waifu testing you
to see whether or not Grace truly does
guide you and drinking whether you are
fit to face the challenge that entails
it seems my worries
torrent had your measure from the very
start you did whereas I merely pretended
imagine not having my measure from the
moment you saw me offer you guidance I
can take you to the round table Hall
Gather in place of tarnished Champions
you ever like stretch your back and it
just hits the correct spot let my hand
rest upon you
that one hit right there I went like
and it just hit
that's a skill issue it
I saw some percentage on Twitter I'm not
it was like 60 of players who bought
Elden ring chat
didn't beat Margate
do you believe that
Molina can ruin my life triumphant face
I'm not saying I'd let melano ruin my
life
I'm not saying that
but I'm also
not saying that
bear
guys watch this
already as much bigger as we had in that
last [ __ ] challenge
[Laughter]
can you believe it
ew no matter how loud you're up right
you can do that
good enough for now
all right where do we go now where do I
go God God
of Freud
got it
Vigor always Vigor every time go to the
room the route table it will trigger a
hidden scene with melena
bet
for all those who are kind enough to
donate gifting memberships gets us
closer to the next goal that is true
chat the next goal which is 500 and
we're at 284 currently
500 will be I will try and beat Elden
ring where every enemy and boss in the
game is doubled
so that means two markets two godrics
two millennias
Two Goats
all of them
are around
do I go get all my flasks and [ __ ]
yeah no no let me get outside of
godric's Boss room
come over let me do that first no no
double Rune drops though
unfortune but of course
actually I can be godric like this and I
know it
I will have to take a shot beforehand
but I can do it
does that mean four godskins I think so
yeah
so if anyone wants to help out toward
that goal
that'd be poggers
also you guys uh in the member only
Discord you guys all voted to just have
members only channels
in the main Discord so I'm literally
getting rid of the Discord only server
um but then you'll have your own
channels and stuff I got to figure out
how to do that
two shots for godskins I mean we're not
doing that now
not yet
uh why am I burping so much
I literally don't get I don't know how
to run a Discord at all
uh but people like talking in there so I
have it
I need like a pro
like a Pro Gamer
at least it's not uh uh what was the old
thing we used to use for gaming
it wasn't Skype what was it called
it's like mainly for gaming
yeah man dude nobody likes the stream
bro nobody ever likes the Stream
it's a [ __ ] shame
yeah TeamSpeak that's what it was called
I used to play uh
you know Counter-Strike
on TeamSpeak
we're pretty good at the game
really dog
get him out of here
let's go
what up angel for anyone that wants the
sakurobu build Katana mainland
Perry Perry Oh that's the Peridot yeah
yeah period of attack uh punished with
Mainland Katana that sounds cool
sunshine
yep
okay
so you guys are really saying a shot
before every boss is that what you're
saying to me
press one in chat if that's what we're
doing
what if we can't Parry time to get good
time to get good at the game
every main boss I'm only gonna fight the
main bosses because that's the only
[ __ ] place
to do anything
okay
I'm not doing this is a huge shot glass
chat I'm doing like that
bear it's a little bit above half
cheers chat tap the table
that was good
I like that
Fireball tastes good
bit
you're not fighting the 20 archery
avatars
no
okay we got I
do I skip cut scenes
no I need time to sober Mighty dragon
they're the true born air
fight Melania and drink one shot every
time you die
now you're dead
about how that'd go yeah
I actually think I can beat Melania in
not that many tries
oh wait I need to add to the shot
counter playing this
I am the Lord
golden
's kind of a [ __ ] though huh
[ __ ] pushover
I shouldn't have talked should not have
spoken words
foreign
we're about to listen to it baby
and thank you for the two dollars I
appreciate that
thank you thank you
[Music]
oh my God
I don't want liver damage for you
I'm fine
I'm fine
I think godric is literally easier than
Margaret list of dragons
lend me thy strength
[Applause]
[Music]
I've never played a Pokemon game before
Zachary
AGT Jack Daniels
yep
one of the best lines in gaming that
right there
foreign
[Laughter]
why did I take one hit man
what the heck
that's a bit unfair
I'm fine
I just got cooked and now I'm dead
though
stop
that attack is so dumb
what the [ __ ]
clean with it though I'm clean with it
bro
yep forgot about that one
that was my fault completely
I am the Lord
of all that is golden
and one day
we'll return together
to our home GG idiots
of cold didn't even die
didn't even die
GG to the Lord
that is now
dead
[Music]
give me that give me that [ __ ]
give me that great Rune baby
give me that great room
do you like carrots yeah carrots are
pretty good
okay it's pretty good
thanks chainsaw
what does AGT stand for
agent
although I just say AGT every time
all right what is what is the percentage
chance I don't get hit by any of these
guys on my way there
the percentage is now higher
percentages are now High
this will be the hard part however
foreign
I mean
you're literally witnessing greatness
right now
pure
greatness
never doubted you you did say a hundred
percent I appreciate that
I was the sober stream going
I mean bad
poorly my friend
poorly
for the sober stream
what build you doing I want to get the
serpent Hunter
and level that
how many runs on this game I've beaten
this game countless times
like a lot
we
what is the building it's a Divine Tower
it's where the tarnish get their [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] am I
we are in fact bearing witness to
Greatness
that is just facts
through actual facts yeah I want to
learn the speed run
for for Elden ring
I want to learn the the actual Speed Run
and like time it and stuff
I think that'd be fun
I think that'd be fun
you are now the Eldon God
I hope you set a limit for how many
shots you'll do
[Music]
a limit has not currently been set but
that's probably a good idea because I'm
already like clearly feeling it
um
oh I'm totally not wasted Miro not yet
uh where do I go now like that I'll go
I should go get all my [ __ ] but it takes
so long man
yeah no a glitchless speedrun is what
I'd want to learn
glitchless
let me let me go over here
I don't like glitch runs either
personally
hi midnight
guys have you liked the stream yet
have you done have you liked the stream
yet
because I don't know how to get more
viewers on YouTube I I literally don't
know how without you all liking the
stream you just kind of have to you got
to do that
you gotta do that and then I think the
viewers get higher I think that's just
what happens
you can dislike the stream if you want I
don't care
like this like it's activity but I'd
appreciate if you liked it because like
a dislike is just not
true
you know where the [ __ ] is the grace oh
it's over here
I don't know why I got so mad about that
I'm sorry thanks midnight
thanks man
we still have zero dislikes well now
someone's gonna dislike because you said
that
it's literally [ __ ] inevitable
like that's just how people work okay
chat we gotta go get
everything
I'm gonna kill this [ __ ] though
I'm not taking a shot for this guy I'm
not doing it that's just silly
like this is such a quick GG
no you can still dislike you just can't
see the ratio
anymore
foreign
GG yet
nice
um
that's not good
en
Rogan ow
ie
yeah Logan Paul drama lol
imagine
foreign
whoops
you said that was gonna be easy I did
say that
I did
I did say that I did say that that's
crazy
I did say that
[ __ ]
I'm not gonna heal I should though
how did that one
shot per death from boss no no no no
dude I'd be dead by now I've died like
10 times
you drink for dying twice to this idiot
I feel like you're right
if I'll I'll take a shot if I beat him
this attempt okay
I will
no stagger there
foreign
huh you all thought I'd just throw no
I'm not a [ __ ]
why did that work that time
oh I didn't have stamina
right right
that attack literally is [ __ ] broken
foreign
[ __ ] that tree right
oh
no bleed yet
I dodged the same damn way as I did
before
I didn't throw I didn't dude
you saw me roll I did
now it's embarrassing
just wanted to say I really love your
streams Jake and you're my favorite
YouTuber by far bro keep growing the
channel Blackheart
Blackheart oh thank you Celeste I'm glad
you enjoy it and I really appreciate the
10. it helps a lot thank you
um
I will keep growing the channel
that's the goal absolutely
hey cheers to you
cheers to Celeste GG
foreign
[ __ ] man
okay we are like oh man okay
excellent
all right watch this
foreign
sometimes I get hit by the attack and
sometimes I don't like it literally
doesn't even make sense
now
I'm dead I'm alive
I should have got my runes
I'm gonna have to do all my flaskies
right now
all them boys
The Shield has a broken hitbox and I
don't want to hear anything else
it's true
did I already up did I
did I upgrade the shot counter no I
didn't
thank you Tim
um
[ __ ]
are we at four
or five
I did okay I'll put it back
how do they have the competency to do
that anyway
okay it's back
have a great dinner midnight have a
great dinner
dude why am I dying to him so much
you know what it is the broken shield
on this guy
when he knew that attack fast
where are these coming from man yeah
good thing I staggered you because I
would have died if you didn't
good thing
foreign
I just need the chat to believe in me
that's not fair at all it's just not
roll
[ __ ]
foreign
like what
for real dude like what are these hits
come on baby
I just wanted more than him I wanted
more than him dude
he doesn't even want it
literally better
I did that more shots in than when I
started
let's go
Tim thanks for the dollar baby I
appreciate that thank you very much
thank you
how many likes are we at
we're literally at more likes than
current viewers
how is that possible
we have more likes than the people that
are literally here
I can't even ask for more likes silly
it's it's done
that means people left
these are not here anymore
yeah some come and go it's okay like
midnight he said he was going to dinner
like the video leave the stream I'd
rather you stay man
I'd rather you stay and chill and be you
know dude so I could have done that
before I fought him
why'd nobody tell me that
why why no one tell me I could I
I'm gonna go get more
like what the heck man
you can check out anytime you like but
you can never leave right that's what I
mean
chat how how does like
tell me this how does Tim the tap man
average like 40 000 viewers on a YouTube
live stream
how does he do that
that's insane
it's 1am where I live I know dude okay
so I usually stream at like 10 in the
morning right but I couldn't tell myself
like that I should do what I'm doing
this drinking celebration stream at 10
in the morning okay I literally had to
wait until now you know what I mean
twitch he streams on YouTube
does he have like half the populations
what's his sub count
for his main Channel because he has a
bunch
I don't have water and I feel like I
should get some
I show speed have 50k and alive and 5K
likes dude is his audience is like 12
they they don't know what a like is
that's what I mean like I didn't want to
drink at 10 A.M this morning I wanted to
wait till 5.
Whiskey's water let's find out
that's that's not water
it's not
that's not water
not water
Tim has 4.8 million
okay
so you're saying I don't have enough
Subs
boom
you said you're saying I don't have
enough Subs that's what you're saying
ow
dude I smell tacos
foreign
's making tacos
look at these clean dodges
who do I like
no
metal babe
with the eight months and Archie's with
the 245 I appreciate it
do I like you
I like you more than you know
I love you
I love you
come come
[Music]
[Music]
twisted
hello
let's go
with the five gifted members
pogging out over here
get some W's in the chat for Twisted
please just Spam it w
thank you man you're a freaking Legend I
appreciate it I can't see where am I all
right this is bad
like you ever hit that moment when
you're drinking and you're just like
dude I I like I hit I hit the spot you
know what I mean
I have not grabbed a map and you know
what I'm not gonna the entire time
because I know where I am
yo [ __ ] the maps
does that make me cool because I don't
hit a map
whoa
it's a lot of water okay here we go
probably get some of that don't die Tori
you [ __ ] okay we're good
[Laughter]
wow
okay I either get nailed by this guy or
I never get hit
there we go
I can't legally drink I can
I certainly can
I'm old as [ __ ]
it makes you cool thank you I I
appreciate that why
good lie
do I have any poppies
so that's a big poppy boy right there I
forgot about that hump strength puppy
pump the strength
[Applause]
imagine getting hyped in the Weeping
Peninsula couldn't be me
you gotta like have a like four shots in
to uh
you know [ __ ] get hyped in the
Weeping peninsula
are you only 28 yeah I'm old as [ __ ]
Nicole
in the gaming world if you're over 13
years old you're old
apparently to every everybody on Twitter
I started a new Twitter account and I'm
starting to regret it
because every time I tweet I get one
like from one of my mods can you believe
that
One One Singular like
I might get two if it's a good tweet
you're 28 too
don't you feel old
I'm 28 and I feel old
that's how I feel
get off Twitter I literally deleted my
Twitter
I deleted it and then somebody's like
dude you're a content creator you have
to have a Twitter
don't I almost grabbed the map even
though I said I'm not grabbing Maps
and then I and then I'll see like
somebody like dream you guys know who
dream is the guy who uh did the weird
face reveal things like the Minecraft
guy he did he'll tweet like LOL
like a bad literally a bad tweet and
he'll get half a million likes like what
the
and I'll tweet like a banger and I'll
get two likes
bro I'm 38 my back hurts when I play too
long you know I got a special chair
that's supposed to help from my back and
it's been really good
I reckon I recommend that you should use
Instagram I do have an Instagram
I do have that
and I actually like Instagram
I like Instagram more than Twitter but I
think
both are dying at this point I don't
know
hmm
your audience is too old for Twitter
um
dude I've been thinking like
why don't I just use YouTube for
literally everything right because
there's the community tab which is
basically Twitter right like I can do
polls and I can like just make
announcements and stuff and people
actually like that
they'll like it and interact with it'll
get like a thousand like
thousands of votes on like polls that I
do on there
um
like what's the [ __ ] point of Twitter
when I when I have the community Tab and
then I have the live tab on here like
why would I ever stream on Twitch when I
could stream on YouTube like I am right
now why why would I
post anywhere else than YouTube
YouTube's the goat for posting
um what else is there shorts why would I
use tick tock when when I got like 250
000 followers on Tick Tock for Rocket
League one minute tip videos that I did
for two years by the way
um and then [ __ ] who's messaging me
stop it now
why would I ever use any other Pro any
other platform than YouTube is the basic
question rank my dinner out of 10.
should I show this
can I show the chat what I was just sent
rank my dinner out of 10. and this is in
the agency Discord that we're gonna get
rid of
it's
dude
dude
dude
where's the window thing there we go
right here
look at this
this
look at this guy's dinner
are you in college
who is this
potato
are you in college right now
what the [ __ ] is happening stop talking
in the in the thingy
Stevie
the college special exactly
okay I'm too drunk to figure out where
that is sorry
nutri-grain bars and ramen noodles that
is the college experience right there
that's some good [ __ ]
you're living
perfectly my friend
your audience is poor I don't know man
y'all give me a lot of money you do you
know that
have you seen this member account go up
like [ __ ] crazy the last week
have you seen this
this
y'all aren't y'all are not poor if
you're giving money to me
I'm poor now
well Logan knows he's the reason this
number's relevant
along with a few other people
[Music]
what am I doing here I hate this area oh
I'm getting uh stuff that's right
[Music]
too many green names
okay so I don't like twitch I think
twitch is a dog [ __ ] website however the
chat on Twitch is a way better
experience do you all agree with that
like you all can have your own color you
can choose your own custom personalized
color
um if you're a sub you still get the
same badge
and and stuff like that the emotes are
way easier to use there and it's part of
the culture and stuff
Nicole
thanks for becoming a tarnish I really
appreciate that thank you
thank you very much welcome
good to have you here
yeah and why is it [ __ ] green
green is my personal favorite color
and I don't I don't want it to be the
indicator of the member in the chat
it's my personal favorite color and it's
not green it's sage green that's my
favorite color big difference between
green and sage green
the badges are cool but like if you
could have your own personalized color
and like a lot of you you know like like
one of my own moderators here Hal Kinsey
you have a more creative name than that
like you could be man called nobody and
you chose to be Hal Kinsey okay man
called nobody was his name on Xbox by
the way that's why I say that are you
gonna get swords sword if you want to do
a strength build I am going to get Irby
I'm gonna get the Hunter's great sword
that's not what it's called
serpent Hunter that's what I'm gonna go
get
yeah so I don't know when YouTube's
gonna make all these proper changes
because YouTube
y'all can agree with me on this YouTube
takes literally [ __ ] forever to make
changes they just take forever and it's
because it's a giant company right it's
a huge ass company has to go through a
bunch of different [ __ ] like I'm happy
we even have gifted members
gifted members are fantastic
but
they take a long time to do stuff
they do like you guys should be able to
choose your own personalized color in
the chat that's just cute like if your
favorite color is purple or red or blue
you could choose that that's easy money
like that just makes people happy and
you should just do that
gifted members are keeping your channel
alive drips
that hurt a little bit
that was hurtful
thank you
that's why Trey's a moderator there we
go
[Laughter]
okay
listen
um do I talk about this I'm drunk so I
probably will
um
I mean okay if you guys had to guess
like with how currency works
do you think I make more more money from
ad Revenue
or memberships from my live streams we
I stream the most out of any Elden ring
content creator besides Josh
the Josh feed I think is what it's
called
band drips we love drips but he was kind
of mean
ain't poor drink water some y'all are
saying members and that's crazy
I have 290 members like do the math
who is that Mythic with the five eight
poor drink water
um
okay
water
okay no so members is a 70 30 split on
YouTube
by the way it's 50 50 on Twitch
50 50. but it's 70 30 on YouTube why
more people aren't streaming on YouTube
with the higher quality I have no
[ __ ] idea uh
70 30 with members
guys
ad Revenue
pays
way more than you think
then you than you would ever think
if your content is monetizable
if you're cussing all the time if you're
[ __ ] you know saying all kinds of
[ __ ] you can get demonetized and you'll
never make a cent
but ad Revenue pays a lot of money
a lot
more than you would think for sure
for sure
you need a patreon dude I had one bro I
did
I
did
and people stopped caring so I stopped
posting to it
is drinking on stream enough to get
monetized no I have to say bad words and
stuff I have to say bad words in the
first like few minutes
which I probably did and then it'll be
like add the ads will like be uh less
you'll make less money if you're not
family friendly
which the the ads that are for my
channel
they don't they don't care as much it
depends on like what kind of Channel you
have because all of my videos and all of
my live streams are for mainly four
people that are over the age of like 15.
right or you got to be like at least in
high school to like like my audience and
these and the advertisers know this
about my channel because of my Analytics
nobody under the age of like 18 watches
my videos or watches my streams
everybody here is like my age or a
little bit younger or a little bit older
so like you won't really care if I say
[ __ ] right
you're just not gonna care
because you're mature like you get it
you know
that we do a thing okay we're good I'm
26 yo [ __ ] yeah dude I'm almost 28. it's
almost my birthday
you're showing an adult game yeah but
it's like very clearly fantasy like do
you see the [ __ ] Turtle building over
here
it's a turtle building
is clearly very fantasy like not real
I'm offended offended by the f word
I'm offended I'm so sorry I'll never
ever ever say it again
[ __ ]
like it's it's a turtle building it's
clearly fantasy and advertisers are not
stupid chat they kind of come off as
dumb because their ads are literally
stupid but it's because 98 of the people
that watch ads are dumb
no no no erby no
no
America's tits
I think for DLC from software should
invite me into Japan I would go to Japan
in a millisecond
um to be a voice actor for a new NPC
what do you guys think about that
can you [ __ ] imagine
and I would be some tarnish that's like
some [ __ ] in the corner that's like too
scared
I don't know why I talked to him
maybe because he has the lantern
no Maps no Maps
dude I got jumped
will this unhurt your feelings
my feelings had to be hurt in the first
place
thank you dress for the two dollars I
appreciate you man
thanks for going along with the meme
chat you you understand who I am right
like now I'm going to actively not get
the lantern
should I shave
metal
I
how are you
are you awake
clearly
who am I where am I going like what am I
doing right now where what are we doing
oh I should go uh upgrade my Uchi
katanas
Christian
becoming a coming a tarnished appreciate
it man
thank you very much welcome
to the agency man I'm gonna start saying
that it's gonna be my thing again
welcome to the agency it's good to have
you yeah your beard looks good though
those eyes tell a story of a Challenger
who's filled his mug thanks find him
well you drunk or something
no
why would you think that
do I seem drunk
your beard looks homeless and then
retracted it I read it first though
I read that man
I saw it
you seem like a forehead
get it
foreign
oh my God
irgs
get it
that was not the proper spot to do the
skip but I did it
what the [ __ ] is this lighting here
PVP
give me a reason to play PVP and I'll
play it
from software
I'm talking to them specifically
I would literally be playing PVP right
now chat
if they gave me a rune Arc for every win
just saying
you can get the joke uh uh I feel like I
shouldn't explain it
you look cuter with the Scruff don't
shave bet
I'll do whatever you say Finn
yo yeah what did chainsaw say bro
yo we we gotta we gotta scrub in here
chainsaw
how'd you become a mod because I want to
be one I've literally known metal for
years
um and we're best friends
and I saw her this year or last year in
Los Angeles where she lives
um
don't have that kind of relationship
with you yet but we'll see
you know so it takes a lot I've known
Trey since I was five
or how Kenzie is Trey by the way right
I've known Trey since we were literally
children
um he's doxing me yeah they're gonna
find your exact position in Los Angeles
foreign
you get it
you get it you get it
you understand
you see that thing over there I'm scared
of that thing
step off
I didn't even know there were lobsters
over there that's crazy
what's your favorite kind of music my
favorite bands are tool
Foo Fighters and Nirvana
those are my top three
yeah you don't live in LA exactly
okay hell
what's your religion I
do we talk about this no we don't this
is like talking about politics religion
all this [ __ ] no no no we don't do that
no no no
no no no no no no no no
believe what you want to believe love
who you want to love think what you want
to think that's what I say
what's your favorite album by Nirvana
whatever the one that has
Smells Like Teen Spirit that one
and Tool kicks ass
almost on the corner that's my work
address if you're picking up what I'm
putting down
true pancakes waffles or french toast
can I have
an ingredient like blueberries
chocolate chips is that a part of the
equation or is it plain waffles pancakes
or french toast
this has to be a part of the equation
yes or no
yes
if I'm if I'm picking plane
like nothing
waffles
if chocolate chips are a part of the
equation
pancakes
French toast
mid
I said it
it's literally a
a piece of bread
I said it
it's bread dog
bread
it's literally bread
I said it
that water was good
why am I over here what am I doing
French toast isn't that good I said it
do what you want with that
[Laughter]
if you had the ability to travel back in
time and kill Hitler would you do it
I have the answer to this
thinking
this family
together
here's URL
L nerd [ __ ]
L nerd
thank you Ashton for the two dollars
here's URL for spending money to tell me
I have an l
imagine
guys
what does every time travel show or
movie tell you
you do not change the past
you don't do it
don't change the past
you don't change it
that's the answer
you don't [ __ ] with it
so don't where am I where's all my maps
I don't even know where I am
where am I going
I should get the dactus medallions
should I
oh we should go to volcano Manor
can I beat Ronaldo like this
yes I can I can do it
I can
Ronnie's rise pointless that's a quest
line we've done that
we gotta get the serpent Hunter
I have to get enough runes to do that
though
I could beat rycard right now that's the
thing
I literally could [ __ ] up Reichard
do you like the channel AGT Jake
um you know like he's okay
all right
he's got some pretty L takes to be
honest
pretty L takes
good videos though
good quality
before every main boss here and I take a
shot
his beard sucks
Fair analysis
what's your opinion on Smoketown
I think he is the best Elden ring
content creator currently
that's my opinion
boom
there's the opinion you wanted
oh [ __ ]
I thought that was gonna kill
me
he won't jump here right
he won't
okay
sometimes I put his sleep stuff on to
fall asleep to
he's got that kind of voice doesn't he
opinion on boxy video
best quality videos ever on the entire
platform
that's my opinion on vati
who blew what off
he repeats himself a lock in bodies of
fraud no they're not
ow you [ __ ] dog bro
oh yeah we're doing damage
foreign
I forgot I was fighting a dog
I should go get my physic yeah
foreign
no death
zero deaths
oh [ __ ]
foreign
is this a main boss
you're saying I gotta take a shot before
this guy
this is a main boss to you
vardy got away with a lot because he's
hot
that's an opinion
he's mean
he's a dog
I love dogs this is a main boss so
you're saying I have to take a shot
he's not mandatory
let me change the shot counter
because that was one
Fireball
literal Fireball
I've also sipping on whiskey for the
last two hours
uh
uh
it's gone
you [ __ ] scholar College Dropout
[ __ ] hit me with that little
this dog's going down to the ASMR
now
what the [ __ ] man
foreign
can the dog do that
foreign
I'm running an ad [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] your heads
they make me money though
they do
okay I'm not dying to this dog three
times I'm just not doing it
great I didn't grab my [ __ ] runes
from before
what the [ __ ] man he went on the
chandelier
what the [ __ ]
I've never seen
he can get stuck on the chandelier man
I didn't even know that
stop hitting me
I'm killing this is the attempt this is
it
you bet you're bad
jump [ __ ] you
that was super [ __ ] risky
look at that
[Music]
one shot in and I kill the boss
an extra shot and he's dead
what an irrelevant boss that wasn't even
worth the shot what an irrelevant boss
I don't even I'm not even using
talismans and that guy's dead
he actually got stuck on the chandelier
though that's funny
that's actually funny bro
who texted me who's texting me
metal
's got my number by the way
he sent a foot pic of her [ __ ] foot
why
I don't even like feet
where does all of my chat get the
impression that I don't that I like feet
I don't
I think feet are feet and that's it
y'all have a good one chainsaw
where do you all get this impression of
me
foreign
give me a percentage that I kill Ronaldo
and this guy
[Music]
foreign
what
happened
[Music]
check your phone
you did not
why are my mods sending me pictures of
feet stop
Trey those were not your feet Danielle
would not allow that
you literally looked up feet on your
phone
probably gross feet and then sent me the
first picture in Google
Metals feet are nice by the way chat
not that I know like what are like good
and bad feet I don't really know
obviously
watch this 360. no scoped
trash
happened again
fall
send your real feet coward no you've
seen my feet IRL
you search Harry feet that's what I
thought
there's like no shot Danielle lets you
have feet like that
he didn't die so where the [ __ ] is he
foreign
[Music]
laugh like these kids
laugh like these kids
why do I look weird what the fly
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right shot
look great
old
wait [ __ ] it's gonna come in quick
little cover
I'll soon birthday a new
Sweeting are fresh and pure
you can birth me in any way you want
mommy what okay what's killer kids
foreign
that's the same kid man
bleed
dead
ow I got hit by a [ __ ] book LOL
I want to listen to Ronnie because you
know I like your voice or whatever what
sorry
what
my beloved
what's the chance for Jake to start
strip dancing
he will become
um 500 members
there it is
do it
upon my name is Ronnie the witch
be disturbed by thee
good [ __ ] Lord
send word far and wide
of the last queen of karya
granola of the full moon
and the Majesty of the night she
conjureth
the Moon
thank you
[Music]
my fate Liars under my moon
[Music]
I was distracted by her feet let's go
again
good call Zeta good call good stuff
just came to watch him die so you're
you're saying you're a hate watcher
is that what you're saying
are you uh declaring yourself a hate
Watcher Mr duck
are you declining yourself as such
maybe a water break
guys I don't take breaks
we know this
uh what
I thought I killed this guy did I not
he he didn't [ __ ] fall
where does he go man
the guy's just gone wait [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
there he is
that's how you do it
hello
arcade
let's go that's a new member right there
thank you very much welcome
yo hi if they get for new members holy
[ __ ]
he's dead now
he did he dead as hell
be dead as hell holy [ __ ] oh my God he
dead
wow imagine
dying to Ronaldo couldn't be me
sleep tight found tight by my mother's
Embers
sleep time
[Music]
by my mother's Amber
three times
[Music]
run
giving them kids
what sweet things
be born anew
they become gravestones
and then she eats them at you like
they're [ __ ] irrelevant
bleed
no bleed but good enough
the blue did not get off
family
together
what we sipping on Jake also when's the
counter-only stream stream 77 trillion 7
7777 nuts
can I get a seven in the chat for Brent
if I kill her this try
the shot counter will be at seven
if you agree to these terms
type seven
once or twice
foreign
not a try
that was not the attempt
oh my God I'm [ __ ] drunk oh my God
foreign
[Laughter]
dude I never drink chat what are you
doing to me dude
dude I hit my knee really hard on my
desk and I can't feel it
how I do ow
I didn't put the lid back on on the
fireball
foreign
there we go
why aren't you incoherent yet
I thought I'd fall off the edge I didn't
I I didn't fall
what about a stoner stream I've never
smoked weed before
ever
dude YouTube ow YouTube literally just
sent me a message saying you should play
an ad right now
press one if I should play an ad
or actually don't press one press
w
ow Fireball is trash liquor
W okay I bet
there's an ad right in your face
right in your face hole
isn't that crazy that I remembered to
put the elevator back down to not waste
time
sweet sweet ad Revenue yeah dude right
you know what's even better than ad
Revenue
even though we already talked about this
and I said that ad Revenue pays a lot
it depends
um members help a lot too just saying
throwing that out there become a member
today
just do it
so does that count as a kid killed
sure [ __ ] does efficient
Chad look at those feet right there
look at that [ __ ] dodged
too good at the game
[ __ ] your fire kid
go play Pokemon if you want to be
[ __ ] Charizard dumbass [ __ ]
dodged
get down here
your stage two is the only relevant part
of this fight
I know I hit the blue early enough to
get it off there there we go
let's go
on her at the beginning of the fight
this is it this is the one
unless she becomes a [ __ ] Moon
randomly dude
the moon's over there
that's just not fair dude
you're not a fair boss
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
where'd the boss go oh she's dead
she's not alive anymore
oh wait Ronnie sent an image of her
hi and we were doing nothing
because she's right there
[Music]
not to be better born than you I'm gonna
point this out because I'm among a
money-hungry [ __ ] but
halcyon's helping out with it but we're
at 20 out of 50 on the goal
and I just beat ranala
thick shots in
I want you to think about that what ELD
what other Elden ring content creator
are you thinking of right now that is
doing what I'm doing right now think
about it
nobody
can you think of another Elden ring
content creator which by the way I'm
going to point this out all of the Elden
ring content creators that you can think
of right now are literally G's
they're all homies they're all good
people
doing what they can do to get you
content
are you begging for memberships the
answer is yes I am
I'm doing that for a reason
all these homies all these homies out
here like I'm saying
do they live stream
along with making high quality content
along with making shorts along with
making Community posts
live streaming as much as myself
they're not
they're not
not doing it
do you think any other Elden ring
content creator out there can beat
ranala
thick shots in and think about this too
think about this man
that can do that
nope
think about it I am Melania
blade of mikola
there it is
I'm just saying
blade of Nicola I am Melania blade of
mcquilla
I'm just saying man twist is out here
helping out
Ludwig's out here helping out baby hello
with the 10 gifted combined
you better count that as two shots that
was one that wasn't two
you know what I did I faked it I drank a
shot and then I held it
hello it made you think I was drinking a
lot but I wasn't it was like one shot it
it might have been like a half
you know what I'll even do this
this is how like honest I am
that was half a shot
[ __ ] I [ __ ] up
hello that was literally half a shot
that was not a full one
what
wait
hello
there you go now it's a full
now it's a full seven
think about it
guys think about this
there's no other content creator hello
out there doing what I'm doing right now
[ __ ] I'm burping a lot
I have the hiccups
foreign
did you eat before this
I had
six
Dino nuggies
and you think I'm lying
chat when I go to the grocery store I
don't get the normal nuggets
that's [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
there's the nuggets
and then there's the dino nuggets
which one do you think I'm getting
think about it
if you don't buy the dino nuggies
which by the way the Chick-fil-A sauce
at the store
30 off
and I'm not even trolling 30 percent off
Chick-fil-A sauce at the grocery store
right
across the way
are nuggets
ice and Nuggets
the nuggies of America that probably
have a lot of [ __ ] in it that I
shouldn't eat but I'm eating it because
you know it's easy
they have the normal nuggets
and then they have
what are called
the dinosaur nuggets
which one
either way
27 years old am I buying Dino or normal
you tell me
go on
you're buying the Dinos
I bought the Dinos
and you know why
I dipped the head
in the Chick-fil-A sauce
and I bite its [ __ ] head off
and then I dip the tail
in the Chick-fil-A sauce
and I bite the tail off
now
it's a torso
some [ __ ] ass torso
and then I eat it
that's a dead Dino Nuggie
Dino nuggies for life that's what I'm
saying bro that's what I'm saying
Matthew thank you for the two bucks
facts
on your message
now think about this
I'm 28 years old and I'm still thinking
about Dino nuggies
I buy the Dinos
over the normal
now any think about this too I do not
have a girlfriend
type one in the chat if this is a reason
or type 2 if [ __ ] are tripping
let's continue
[ __ ] be tripping
facts thank you chat [ __ ] be tripping
if they don't think the same way I do
about Dino nuggies I don't want them
I do not want them
I dip Dino in ketchup to pretend it is
blood
respect
potato that's respect if I didn't see
the Chick-fil-A sauce I would have got
the Heinz Ketchup and I would have been
doing the same thing as you my man
respect
respect
I wouldn't say [ __ ] but yeah to
I agree Zeta that's a good point they
are not [ __ ]
they're just concerned of a 27 year old
eating Dino nuggies and I think that's
respectable
but
if
if
that is a breaking point for them
you got to cut them off entirely
you have to
thank you again for tater chat
where am I going and what am I doing
I don't know where I am right now
bro's been talking about Dino nugs for
five minutes
I was looking for who asked nobody
nobody else
no one
we gotta go to Reichard
that's facts
they're bowellas what's a bowela
what's that
chat No Cap I can beat Reichard right
now
and I'll bet on it
now can I beat the godskin noble to get
there
no
I gotta go see my boy real quick
I have to go see my boy
who's my boy chat
who is it
it is certainly not this guy
talk about a simp and a half and then
becomes even more of a simp
too hot
imagine
but one day without fail you will have
your wish
please grant me if forgiveness go in
America
hello I find Queen America to be the
most interesting character in the entire
game
anybody else
Nine Flower I [ __ ] love you and I
cussed that is actually a concern to the
ad revenue of the VOD after the stream
is over
and I'm not kidding
I cuss for you
thank you very much welcome to the
community I love you very much welcome
Queen America is the singular most
interesting character in the entire lore
of the game
and I think a close second to that is
mikola
because I'm not kidding chat
you know when I made the um
my last video the last lore video
about nikola's dream
I'm not kidding when I say this they
literally ripped the plot
out of Griffith from berserk
and made a mikola
and I am literally not kidding they took
that concept
it put him into mikula of Elden ring
backs or no
it is literally the same [ __ ] thing
same thing
he's turned into a completely different
person
and he is going to be so [ __ ] mad
when he finds out that we killed Melania
at 25 vigor
doing a challenge run
with The Bloodhounds Fang
six hours of attempts
188 attempts and she is dead
he's dead as a [ __ ] bro
he died she's no longer alive
she dead
Melania started it though thank you
thank you
I have a question for everyone in the
chat real quick
why does everyone try to kill us
why
are they racist against tarnished
why we are here to literally mend the
Elden ring and restore destined death so
that you can [ __ ] die a proper death
what's wrong with that man
get over it if you don't like it
we were literally brought back to the
lands between to mend the Eldon ring by
the greater will
and look at [ __ ] huge over here
literally doesn't consider himself a
prisoner and he has a chain to his
[ __ ] ankle
to help us
to help us create a god slain weapon
to kill a manifestation of the greater
will
isn't even the greater will
not even real
even though it says God's slain it's not
a god apparently according to YouTube
comments
blah blah blah
what's going on man
why does everyone attack us
why
I have the reason
are you drunk no
where are you getting this from
this is how I'm talking right now is
like literally how I talk in every video
who is it it's me I didn't notice you
there I'm sorry I'll be doing my job
same as ever thank you just lay out your
arms I will I I appreciate what you do
smithing Master huge
I appreciate you thank you for what you
do I know you don't want to do it and I
appreciate you
thank you very much you're a a literal
Legend I have not picked up a [ __ ]
root like any Smithy stones at all
hero
shut up and kill some [ __ ]
that's fair
you know what you're right
I'll shut up
y'all don't want me to talk anyway
Fair
I respect it
um
how do I get to Landell
I I I don't think we go the route you're
thinking
I love chatty Jake am I talking too much
is that what you're saying
I'm I'm literally not gonna say another
word until I get to Landell
and it's your fault chat not anyone in
particular but it's your fault
I'm not gonna speak until I get there
it's your fault
You Know Who You Are
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
oh yeah
you are enjoying myself and King as
remedy together
all right you stop talking now kill
something
colon underscore hello gotta go now Jake
you the best GN everyone underscore giga
foreign
thank you
all right
remedy
together
a quiet place the lands between
[Music]
foreign
foreign
oh
welcome
dear customer yes right this way
[Music]
but
okay enough of you said one so I'll talk
did you miss me that was a long time can
you imagine being this drunk and but
being that disciplined to not talk
foreign
did you miss me
it's me
it's me it's Jenny
wow you imagine being that discipline
though even drunk to do that is that
crazy
imagine if I had that kind of discipline
to make uh videos
we'd be Beyond vati at this point
would literally be Beyond two three
million subscribers
if I had
that kind
of
discipline
no shut up again okay it's just cause
metal said that now I'm not gonna talk
until I get the other medallion
yell at her if you're mad
foreign
thing he likes it when you yell at her
she's like that kind of girl
oh we went to tumbling class oh my God
you went to Tumble okay I'll shut up
foreign
foreign
okay I'll keep talking because of drips
Jake pretending he knows how to read
are you kidding have you seen my videos
chat if you've watched all my videos you
would know that I know [ __ ] all about
this game
I don't I don't know [ __ ] anything
this is why body has three million subs
and I don't
I'm speaking facts currently
[ __ ] is that oh it's some summoning
[ __ ]
I've had to pee for an hour can I go pee
or no
did you just roast yourself yes welcome
to content creation where you're
truthful about how dog [ __ ] you are
about your content
it's not that good
but sometimes it's pretty good
I have to get water if I go pee
that means I have to go upstairs man
also I wanted to say this thank you for
300 members
collapse in the chat 300 members the
goal is 500 but 300 is a new high for us
thank you very much
305.
[Music]
thank you very much
Gigi show us your P demonetized I'm
running an ad
just cause you said that I'm running the
ad currently we went down in viewership
wow
like the Stream
we have 280 likes in 146 people
go pee and get water
remedy
together
you'd have more viewers if you got a
lantern
I forgot something
dude my computer is running right now
I forgot something man
I don't know it was a
I didn't I didn't want to go all the way
upstairs for water
I did forget to wash my hands because I
do have a clean dick
what the [ __ ] did I just get texted
right now
Pakistanian writing torrent imagine
metal said I look so [ __ ] good right
now you don't even know I'm feeling this
shirt
what do I do with that chat what do I do
with that information
that happened 30 minutes ago what
happened 30 minutes ago guys started to
speak incoherently
chat press one if the title is accurate
press one if the title is accurate
I've been talking for five minutes
you know what's crazy
a lot of people die right there
okay what would you have said if you
knew I would say it out loud metal
because like you know what I'm gonna say
I still haven't got a map yet
foreign
oh my God I have 7
000 700 hours in this game
you think I need a map
LOL
right Archies thank you man
that's the confidence I needs here's
that butthole
hmm
oh
that's so sweet you're right
you're right
demonetized dude I said
that doesn't mean nothing
why is my computer running so hard right
now
remind me to get the uh the sacred tear
over here
base camp question mark hello are you
[ __ ] blind
sir are you blind
how was your day Jake
my day was really good thank you for
asking nobody ever asked me that thank
you very much
my day was really good how was your day
and thank you for the money thank you
Mike isn't working
I'm smart enough to figure this out yes
it is don't do that
it's working
don't do that don't do that
pillows
wait
what is wait
what did Taryn say
those bloody those body pillows you
ordered came in
chat I am 27 almost 28 years old
I am not that down bad
okay
I'm really not
I've had my experience
all is well
I'm looking for my wife
not some like down bad
person okay
eight shots in we in this together are
together
thank you Mythic appreciate you man
hope you're having a good day thank you
Jacob's a [ __ ] no
porn
I meant War
I see
foreign
actually
that hit me that's some Call of Duty
[ __ ] hit marker [ __ ]
I am anything but a [ __ ] though
I am not a [ __ ]
I am not a thought
right dude we're at 42 out of 50 on the
sub goal can you imagine
so a [ __ ] yeah yeah I'm a [ __ ] I'm not
a [ __ ] but I'm a [ __ ]
that's very accurate
foreign
chat
chat
I am so down bad for this one girl dude
it's [ __ ] pathetic and I shouldn't be
like this
there it is
oh [ __ ] do I have both medallions
together
you sound like you need to drink water
I made need to drink water
Nicole
thank you for the five I appreciate you
very much
but
should I drink water
at this point I don't know what water is
[Laughter]
that made me laugh that's good
I'm almost out
of all I think we've hit our limit or
we're close to it
I would say like one or two more shots
maximum chat
one or two more shots of Maximum and
then we should stop
vodka is watered colored it's not
colored though
wanted opinion
that's an that that's Rob that's a
[ __ ] like Twitter opinion
because you're wrong water looks like
vodka and vodka looks like water
in the time it took you to go to the
Grand lift of world you could have
gotten this water in back
true
you're not wrong
you are not wrong at all and I'm sorry
for letting you down I'm sorry
see that Grace not gonna get it
I'm sorry
did I let you down
did I not make make enough videos
this year last year this year
did I not do enough for you
should I have done more
I didn't want to kill that goat anyway
you see your profile pic same color as
vodka
same color
vodka's water with teeth
you're speaking facts this
is true
Nicole
I'm gonna go get water for you
after I get all these seeds
that's why I'm here
because I'm not that drunk
I'm not even gonna hit these Graces
they're worthless I'm never gonna come
back
boom
boom
I'll go over here to avoid the gargoyle
dehydrated you shall go for a nice long
drive on a school zone
that is a bad joke
everyone press l
I'm literally drunk and know that
driving drunk is stupid
and I'm drunk
l
AP potato l
did I avoid Margaret completely
he's so irrelevant bro
so irrelevant bro
[Laughter]
guys I'm drunk and I'm telling y'all
right now do not drive under the
influence of anything at all
if you do you're a [ __ ] l loser I'm
gonna go get some water cause Nicole
told me to I'll be right back
together
this one's for Nicole
I forgot something
no I didn't
this is for you Mythic
where's my headset
found it
found it
he's on the table in the basement
somewhere
where am I going right now
uh
serpent Hunter
renala
I'm drunk and I know Renault is dead
I think
did I kill Ronaldo
or did I just get the medallions in
there and I got here that way
locate ubul ubel's dead on all of his
accounts
or ban Not Dead
I hope he's alive because I hope he's
doing okay
I killed Ronaldo
good
it'd be embarrassing if I did not
have you picked up any smithing Stones
probably not
probably not
I've killed a bunch of bosses though
where is Reichard man
where is that snake
that's
a
snake
I gotta kill a [ __ ] fat ass though
first
for all these people
[ __ ] you
snake also Nicole
thank you for telling me to get water I
actually feel a little better after
drinking it so thank you
literally the only person in chat
looking out for me
I'm pretty sure she's [ __ ] new
ish
mad
only person looking out for me
just to hydrated that's how it works
YouTube reminded me to play an ad again
I'm doing it
because we keep going down in viewers
even though it's the best content you've
seen in Elder ring and six months
imagine
literally the best content you've seen
in Elder ring and we keep going down in
viewers because this is not the normal
dime I stream at
what the [ __ ] man
playing an ad
monetize this stuff man
you guys know what's crazy
is we did the whole challenge right we
did the whole challenge
of
spinning the wheel for levels right
and
I am not gonna lie to you
that video
flopped
and it took me two entire days to edit
record and edit
full days of work
in the video flocked man
the [ __ ] dude
y'all that down bad for lore
it flopped man
it was so good
the video is so good
but no one watched it dude
I shouldn't say no one because thousands
of people did and everyone who watched
it really liked it
but I'm comparing myself to myself
from May where I got 300 000 views on
every video
so like where am I at
you know
what do I do from there
dude that's shrew metal that's where I
became a [ __ ] idiot content creator
by the way
I became an idiot dude when metal and I
did a co-op
uh seamless Co-op video together
that video was [ __ ] gold
it was gold it was literally
one of the best video one of the best
videos on the channel I'm [ __ ]
slurring words I'm sorry
um one of the best videos on the channel
is when me and metal did Co-op together
seamless Co-op dude he got like 10 000
views when I was averaging like 250k at
the time
dude
I am such an idiot
like
imagine caring about views imagine bro
because the content was good
the content was good
I should have kept going
right
because I shouldn't even be saying that
the video from the the last video I made
flopped because it didn't
can you can you imagine all the millions
of people out there who want a 7 000
view video
it's that's incredible
they Imagine 7 000 people in a room
that's incredible that's so many people
that's a lot compared to 300 000 not
very much but
still
[ __ ] the money money's [ __ ] dog [ __ ]
just make good content and what me and
metal did with the seamless Co-op is
good as content
it's one of the best videos I've ever
made was that [ __ ]
and I stopped because it was like oh I
got 10 000 views that's a lot
that's so much that's that's so many
views compared
[ __ ] it good content welcome
that guy cares about views I don't
I don't even know about this vid but I
followed for the Lord vids thank you
more than I ever got on my videos see
like every everyone out like
guys
here
like
cynical as well like
just make content that you think is good
I love you man I love you too thank you
for being here Mythic I appreciate you
but
here's how you be happy making content
on YouTube
make [ __ ] that you that you feel in your
bones is good
if it doesn't get views who cares
whatever let's say it gets a hundred
views which to our standards would be
extremely low extremely low
those imagine a hundred people in a room
they would all like all flipping out at
how good it is who cares
like that that's good
that's awesome
there's content Graves out there that
get mad at a hundred thousand views
you get like imagine if Mr Beast got a
hundred thousand views he'd be [ __ ]
[ __ ] his pants
kill [ __ ] please
okay
It's Gonna be Me
that's your fault
it's on you
we were having a good conversation and
you [ __ ] it
just saying
I don't even know the last thing I
[Music]
look where I am
look how far back we went because of a
negative mindset
look how far back we are because of a
negative mindset
that's on you buddy
look how far back you went negative
mindset you're all the way back in
[ __ ] Landell
the outskirts of Landell
we were literally in watch this watch
watch
watch
like we you think we wasted a bunch of
time
listen
like I played this game so many times I
don't even I don't even [ __ ] care
what happens I'm just happy this game
exists
do you know how many dog [ __ ] games we
got before this game came out oh my God
Elden ring
restored my happiness
with gaming
I don't care that I died I don't give a
[ __ ]
because this shit's gold
it's just it's all good man I'm out here
having a good time
drinking way too much
in playing Elven ring and I'm so good at
the game I'm literally past what
everyone can do
kill me mommy there we go
grab the Fireball and not this
Hey listen listen chat listen listen
there were people out there who thought
God of War Ragnarok would have won game
of the year there were people that
thought that was a thing
dude there were people who thought God
of War Ragnarok would beat eldering
like those people exist
they exist bro
like
God of War Ragnarok is one of the best
games I've ever played in my life played
the whole thing non-stop the day it
released the day it released I played it
for a week until I beat it
off stream didn't give a [ __ ]
dude
dude
Elden ring like God of War took over my
life for a week
Elden ring
changed my life
not it's
just not a comparison
whoa let's go
hello
thank you Zeta I appreciate you very
much you've been very
generous to the channel
and I am happier here thank you
and if you got a gifted from Zeta
and you don't say thank you
I don't like you
I literally don't like you if you don't
say thank you to Zeta
oh
it's cause you didn't say thank you
oh I'm still here let's go
Lord Farquaad
it was probably from Logan
you're good
I said Thank You For You
where do I drop down from here where I
don't die is it right here
it's not it's not there
eldering should have won music
everybody hold
everybody hold
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
that's it
that's all I need to say
and all I should say
and also I'm gonna play the best song in
the soundtrack real quick hold on
I'm gonna play the best song in the
entire game
Full Blast by the way
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
loss of Ragnarok by the way
[Music]
[Music]
this loss to Ragnarok I'm just gonna
point that out as many times as I can
wait it's not over this loss of Ragnarok
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
rip Batman
[Music]
[Applause]
hit it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so just want to point out again
[Music]
that what we just listened to Lost to
Ragnarok
I'm just gonna point that out
laughs
oh my God imagine
you good bro I'm better than good
see me just lose it to four to sacks
did you just listen to Fortis ax in
wonder why eight shots in I'm vibing
couldn't be me
metal why are you sending me snaps
why are you sending me snaps
that's pretty cool though
together
if Jake doesn't finish tonight he has to
film as many drunk streams as he needs
to beat the game press one and chat if
you agree with Hal
press one if you agree with Hal
we get out of here
can I get out of here
you can tell me if your fit isn't sick I
would tell you if it wasn't sick
I would tell you
and it's it's literally that cool
I'm in like full honesty mode
you guys could ask me anything and I
would answer a hundred percent honestly
Metals fit is sick
where the [ __ ] I am
sorry I'm really gross
I'm sorry
do you want to ban me no I love you
I would never ban you
on purpose
is this a boss fight
you hate me no I love you too
jakey's your penis 10 inches long or 11
inches long
uh it's neither of those lengths that's
my answer
neither not neither
what the [ __ ] am I looking at right now
foreign
I don't hate anyone
I literally don't have hatred toward
anyone ever
this malachath make you Randy I don't
know what Randy means malakath does make
me feel some kind
um some type of way though
is this a boss if show shots
I don't have that many shots left in
that [ __ ] Fireball
stand
Smith even fours that's kind of weird
isn't it
big drinks here's what up four quad
sorry I'm looking at my phone real quick
I got a follower on Twitter
what
holy [ __ ]
unreal
I got a singular follower on Twitter
chat holy [ __ ]
it's from Chuck
[Laughter]
thank you Chuck
I don't know who Chuck is
I got one follower
is that the only way to get out of here
by the way Chad is if I beat those
bosses
it's not
you want a follower I got you I mean ugh
do you got like do you guys think I
should even give a [ __ ] about Twitter
because you know it's like I'm a content
creator so they're like yeah you should
[ __ ] care about Twitter I don't even
know
if I should care
I don't use it that's fine
you can warp I can't right now
I don't want to warp though I want to go
to where I was
I just didn't want to like go all the
way back to where it was
uh oh I'm gonna die
I didn't die
slime
would chew a heavier weapon like a sword
you've seen the sword right now
did I jump down here again
why am I down here again
oh I have to get out using the virgins
thank you for actually answering my
question
hi thank you
I really need to go to get back to Eldon
ring it's been months
Dude tell me about it
like I've been playing Elder ring but
like 98 of the community has not
and that sucks
kill the maidens
I'm literally the best in the game
this boss fight easy peasy
don't spin in a circle
she's spinning in a circle
I just said not to do that
I can do it though
I can and I will
and it will be literally impressive when
I do
throw that ax in a circle throw that ax
in a circle
did I get the right song Zeta
is that what you're referring to
throw that ax in a circle
throw that ax in a circle watch this
wait
I don't have a rune Arc why are they so
[ __ ] rare
what the hell why are they so rare
what do it once threesome what okay
threesome
what okay
huh
guys I said to follow me on Twitter and
someone followed me on Instagram
who did who did that
pretty pistol designs okay that's that's
chill thank you
who followed me on Twitter though
demon dragon
that's cool name
I ain't gonna cap
that's a cool name
I'm not even mad
Jake dies to a scrub Trey have you ever
beaten this boss
and be honest
you're dragging these nuts
through
the snow so you guys can see how long my
hair is
just don't kill me
foreign
can I beat this
am I capable of doing this currently
or no
as I roll in lava
he's a lot or I think the water I got
was actually pretty helpful
like am I capable of beating this right
now or is it just like kind of a lost
cause
if sober easy
you see that's where you're a little bit
misinformed
I am not sir
thank you
it's a stretch really
that really insta kills you damn bro
if you don't jump down from the grace
you can just TP right yeah I can
should I leave
I don't think this is gonna happen guys
it's already been too many attempts but
it's the only Grace I have here bro I
can do it I I can
I believe in myself I'm the best
all right if I can beat this in this
mindset in this state
I need you guys to tell me
that I am the best Elden ring content
creator
okay if I can do this
I need that affirmation
okay
I'm gonna try really hard
foreign
holy damage
damn [ __ ] get out of here
get on
trash
I'm doing things right now
no
[Music]
I think I think the goal for the night
is just to get the serpent hundred sword
definitely possible
enjoy
it's gonna get hurt this quick
why have you done any streams until this
moment
Peter
you must be new welcome
ow
all right oh what
I've streamed for a year on this
platform and four years on Twitch
I don't know if I can do this guys
I don't think I can do this
so many people call me Jack and I don't
understand
so many people call me Jack
it's not my name
it's not my name at all
like that's not my name
really no what
I can't do this
I think I should leave bro
one more maybe several more attempts
I'm getting unlucky
a little bit
what do I swallows here
if you give up you have to take a shot
okay
this isn't even worth it like I don't
even think I get out of the area I'm in
if I kill them
what is [ __ ] hitting me dog
I can see why they called him [ __ ]
virgins dude
nobody wants to [ __ ] him
you see that you see what I just did
what
this this boss fight sucks dick who
thought of this
uh
uh
[Music]
wait what cliff
cliff
pee again
poor decision making brocky to this
point
why am I here
how did I how did I end up in this
situation
oh I wanted a serpent Hunter like fast I
have to kill the [ __ ] Noble
let's kill these [ __ ] and then the
noble
this is not possible
it's not
it's not
possible
currently
can I get out of here without fighting
them that's my question why can't I hear
anything that's why
I turn my headset all the way down
no
I feel like you don't know
the wizard up here shooting me with your
wizard [ __ ]
didn't I see you in carrion Manor
why are you here
turd
I have to pee
you haven't done any streams maybe for
one week is that a long time is that a
long break for you okay I gotta pee I'll
be right back
foreign
Chad I can't see anymore
[Laughter]
uh uh [ __ ] I think I'm [ __ ]
aren't I
kind of
oh
I think I'm [ __ ]
hmm
I'm not going to beat them
I'm not gonna do it
it's a it's a gank fight
okay that's why
that's why I'm not gonna beat him
so I feel like that's fair
um
I feel like I'm not gonna get very far
from this point on
to be honest with you
shot
I feel like a shot won't help
at all
easily patience
I'm drunk though so that's not a thing
I'm gonna go through the regular way
like a smarty pants
not supposed to help true
[Laughter]
why do I
I'm somebody leveled I feel like I
barely [ __ ] leveled
wait never mind
[Music]
go hit them while you dodge attack
oh [ __ ]
brooded true didn't I go through this
whole [ __ ] area and didn't someone
coax me to jump off a cliff and that's
why I'm not there
and I would have hit a side of Grace
right outside volcano Manor and we
wouldn't have to do this again
because of that person in chat
am I right on that or not
you chose to jump off the cliff no I was
coerced into doing so
I was coerced
not right
mind control is that my fault that I was
mind control
hi Slugger hello how are you
alone
oh hello
God damn [ __ ] you're looking good girl
damn that lost Grace discovered though
bye brah he's so [ __ ] hot God damn
um
[Music]
God damn
anyone else get all turned on when you
see a side of Grace press one if you
agree
the higher drunk just drunk
just that
[ __ ] it okay
wait okay we're good where are the what
okay
sorry
I just I just want to beat Reichard and
then I'll call it a day like that's
gotta be as far as I can go
scale from sober to reform Orthodox
rabbi
[Laughter]
uh game of the year that's where I'm at
game of the year
let me out let me out of here let me out
of this dungeon
okay
perfect
uh I'm at game of the year
game of the year
I'm definitely not at reform Orthodox
rally Bill Clinton however
that's a lot that's insane
my water bottle fell over it's empty
though
empty cup
what am I looking at right now I'm like
texting while I'm climbing a ladder
okay
bye Morgan no I didn't
I thought Margaret who is morgot
you know a lot of people for like six
months were like dude Margaret and
morgot are different people
you [ __ ] stupid
there are still people that say that in
my comments I'm like what
the same person very clearly
nah dude they're [ __ ] twins dude
I get comments like that I want you to
know that I get comments that are like
dude Margaret and Morgan are twins
they're going to write an article about
the stream this streamer played while
drunk what happened next will surprise
you
what what's been surprising Zeta
what's been surprising
honestly not
just hopefully I don't jump off a cliff
this time and miss the side of Grace
because we've already been here an hour
ago something like that
want Abby
they are different one as an i and one
as an o
right
right right right sorry yes right this
way of course that's incredible evidence
insanely accurate evidence
of this
oh my God
you know what makes me kind of mad chat
that I streamed at a time that I'm like
not usually streaming at
I just couldn't do a drunk stream middle
of the day I just couldn't do it that
seems sad when it's like light out that
I just straight like take a bunch of
Fireball shots that's just not a good
that's just not okay
I had to wait till five I had to
but I usually stream at like 10 in the
morning
that's when I started but this is not
can't do that
not today
foreign
I feel like we've leveled up not at all
barely if any at all
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
here we go I'm not fighting that falling
star Beast I don't have a blunt weapon
literally worthless to do so
yeah Zeta if you have to explain a joke
to somebody that that that just means
that they're silly a goose that they're
a silly goose
I did not jump off a cliff I did not do
it
you're welcome
have I gotten a map yet
probably not
I hope not
I don't want a map
no map playthrough LOL
no map
no map run
we made it
volcano Manor
imagine
being a [ __ ] you mad at this boyfriend
fight balling sir bees yeah okay let me
just stall a bunch of time there you go
that would be the same thing
same [ __ ] thing we
I feel like tanith is low-key like
fine
you know I mean
I feel like she's like under the radar
fine as hell
I'm getting to the damn Church
I'm getting to the church
snail [ __ ] that snail wait yeah [ __ ]
that snail
thought I died
here we go keep going
keep going
this is gonna be a bloodhound to my left
[ __ ] that guy I'll fight that guy
I go through here
and then suddenly on my left
Church
wow I should rest
Leonard Reichard before eating Crucible
night game what what the [ __ ] Aaron what
the [ __ ]
what
if only she wasn't a cannibal it's just
cause she's a simp for Reichard
I mean she's sipping bro like can we
blame her
she's sipping so hard for Rye card
so hard
I'm sitting really weird in my chair I'm
sorry
can't sit normal
hey that kind of hurt damn [ __ ]
that hurt
damn that hurt a lot actually
I do not think I can beat the godskin
noble like this
I've leveled up like twice
where am I
right
what's this
yeah I love getting up I I I love
picking up a blood clot
you need levels and smithing stones
yeah I do
you're right
you're just
you're correct
is there a side of Grace over here
in that door there is
it might help a little bit
foreign
you're not wrong
you're not wrong
uh
nice
here we go
foreign
here we go
hard to see in the dark yeah imagine if
I picked up a lantern
yellow is so crazy about you just love
these lanterns dude
couldn't be me man
foreign
what are the [ __ ] chances
that I beat the god second Noble
give me a percentage
is godskin Noble a boss like a main boss
first try three percent
yeah
y'all can't even see me
there we go
I ain't dumb enough to not hit this
do you ever post about the fallen leaves
yeah uh go watch thank you Eldon ring
for that
gosh
like uh two videos ago
how's your pairing not attempted
not attempt
you got a doobie
uh
tough topic but it's okay
it is what it is
I would like to do that again though
gotta get me in the right headspace chat
we'll get there
that's bad damage that's straight up bad
[Music]
this isn't poor damage
foreign
very bad damage
don't have sleeping Paws now
I didn't have a stamina no stamina oh
[ __ ] I died
um I feel like we should go
agreed Maybe I don't think we're gonna
beat that guy
do you know what's crazy if I beat the
godskin noble
then I can definitely beat Reichard
totally confident in that
totally confident Reichard
hold on let me let me go do a thing
way over leveled yeah a lot of people
were bro
foreign
no Maps
a pimp name
wait I'm dead
[Music]
guys I'm too far gone I'm not gonna lie
bro
like dude I can't even see
guys
I'm starting to get dizzy from being on
torrent for one
that's bad
foreign
dude look at this
water gone
do schwats why do you want me to do
squats
on camera bro
what's up bro
all right this is like one of the early
areas I know for Smith and stone once
butt facing cam
true
cat I'm not your [ __ ] okay
I'm way better
yeah I'll pay for that [ __ ]
five thousand members you all know what
happens
what happens at five thousand members
no cap
what happens
we're at 310.
what happens man
aged stream no only fans
I'll start an only fans account
five five k
5K
5K
play with viewers that sounds fun
actually
I would do that
doesn't have to be that much
dog you did a [ __ ] 360 up in this
[ __ ] bro to hit me bro what the [ __ ]
bro
all the smithing sounds God damn
did Brent go to horny jail that's where
he always is dude
he's never been anywhere else ever
it's the only place he knows
Elden ring cosplay only fans
1 000 members I do a Ronnie cosplay
think about that
let's give it a thought you know
let's put it out there in your brain
I listen to every message ever
I never ignore a message
radon cosplay
or Reichard oh [ __ ]
I gotta become a
[Music]
why am I killing this guy no clue
I'm gonna
another horny Brent
why are Brent so horny
dead boy
dead boy yeah the Boya
dead boy yeah
dead boy yeah
dead
this is why I want to shave like I feel
like my beard is just [ __ ] itchy at
some points
itchy weird
like you know [ __ ] itchy right
itchy nothing else but itch
you the oil or lotion then is that why
or is it because like my hairs are like
not
to use that good you know what I mean
makes you look zaddy-ish what's zaddish
mean
all right
hey yo what's that ish okay a couple
upgrades there can we beat godskin Noble
like this I don't know we about to find
out though we about to find out though
bro
I don't know what zadius means
natural oils I actually have beard oil I
just haven't used it very much I
probably should
we'll help soften the hair
okay
is this fact or myth
if I like let's say I shave
and then I put beard oil on the entire
time it's growing back and then shave
beard oil it'll like grow better when I
do that
or should I just put it on now
Factor myth
did I even upgrade yeah I did
I did
[Music]
not better damage chat it's not better
foreign
that's good though
oh he was fine okay that's good
as long as I'm fine
as long as I'm looking good to my people
then I'm happy
doing some pretty good dodging right now
no cap
nice belly flop idiot
was that a bleed
I need to know
that even hurt
I need another blue flask and I can beat
them
foreign
flask and I can beat the guy
thousand percent
remember there's a tail yeah he's a
snake
he's a stink
why is my phone dead
the [ __ ] I am zero percent goddamn
wait blue flask at least one
did I do too to be safe yay
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
well Jake is responding to their move
sets
right
unconscious
unconscious movement
clone what dude my phone's dead look
look wait look
wait
show them
show them
hey look I'm pressing
nada
you know what's crazy I don't have any
anybody blowing up my phone it's just
dead
it's dead that's it
foreign
opening there Mr godskin Noble
[Music]
thanks Joey
good
all good
where am I right now hello
[Music]
why do I have this guy's moveset down
foreign
what's going on
whoops
that's just unlucky I can beat him
though that was straight up just unlucky
it's been four hours since first drink
um I mean I've had eight shots so like
what what what what
do you thinking
what do you think bro
bigger check
what's new
what's new with us playing all the ring
dude
smoking stream I've never smoked before
so
it's not happening
early Fireball man very early Fireball
very nice
let me go let me go through this
is good
good
Fireball
Miss
backstab
good job Acres
happy for you and your dad
Howie
that hurt
[Music]
that Miss
that certainly didn't
certainly
what
do the thing
[ __ ] you
[Music]
how
foreign
I can do this man
oh okay this game's broke
that I just literally confirmed that the
game's broken right there
it's broke
broken
[Music]
I confirmed it just now
I did you saw that right
I confirmed it
he literally went out of a roll to hit
me
and then went back into the roll
that was broke like that was dumb that
was straight up stupid
and everybody who saw that knows it
I can totally beat him though right
there
I'll take a shot when I beat him
and then we gotta fight Reichard and
then we're done
foreign
[Music]
foreign
I'm super focused right now it's insane
Focus
[Music]
foreign
Focus right now
foreign
I'm like on another level right now
I'm beyond time and space
[Music]
too close that was my fault
it's close
it was a close one
we're dummy
oh
my God [ __ ] by a candle
imagine
good
I'm literally that good
I'm that good at this game and y'all
just saw it
y'all saw it dude
I'm that good
foreign
Ty if he can do that
ask him
ask vati dude can you beat godskin Noble
volcano Manor uh nine shots in eight
shots in
can you do that
AGG Jake can
you can he did it you did the thing
he did the thing man he did that
let's go
now it's time for Rye card and then
bedtime
let's go
okay chaos
gamer chair I have the best gamer chair
I love my chair
your hell it's Harnish thanks Brent
pellet tarnished
you're beyond the spectrum of tarnish
you are tarnished you're super tarnished
you're like tarnished times
15.
at bati can you tweet it
dude he actually gets likes on his
tweets I don't so that's that's already
an l
I don't want to take a fat L like right
there you know I mean
I gotta go get the uh seven
I gotta go get the seven
another Brent nah we gotta sell this
no no you're Brent tastic and that's
Brent got it
is that fair
that guy's Brent and you're Brent tastic
he would legit instant ratio you yeah he
has a lot of simps that's why
I don't
even though I do
you know what I'm saying
you get what I'm putting down
um I gotta go this way actually
you'll like my tweet thanks I I like
don't tweet so good luck
imagine competing with another Brent
imagine having the name Brent honestly
it's like Brad you know
it's like
like oof sorry
I'm kidding sorry
yeah you should be working with your
Brent Brent I'm dead
this game is so
unlucky sometimes
yeah it was Fireball we're almost out
it's gone
yep
yo I thought you should know you'd die
thanks man
appreciate that info
thank you
I like how I talked like a [ __ ] idiot
yo thanks bro
yeah yeah did I die
yo Chad did I die yo make sure to like
the stream go ahead and become a member
real quick
hey yo what up chat hey yeah
yeah this is my first from software game
bro
pretty good game
it's like all right I think I prefer
Call of Duty Modern Warfare
I'm talking about classic Modern Warfare
2 dude
the new one's pretty good too bro
yeah
I stream on YouTube by the way
yeah
I'm not a huge fan of twitch dude
pretty good game
there's no discover belly on Twitch yet
there's no discoverability on YouTube
either dude but you know opinions
[Laughter]
what idea nothing bro you're good bro
don't worry about it
no you can't break me I'm already broke
I've been broke for years
I've been broke
I'm gone
do I sound like any of those Call of
Duty streamers you guys you guys watch
you even watch Call of Duty
I liked and retweeted every tweet it's
kind of weird Austin
honestly I think I'm just gonna delete
that Twitter and I'm not kidding
I had a Twitter with 2 000 followers
from rocket League years ago
like a year ago
deleted
because I didn't like Twitter and then
someone was like dude you got a [ __ ]
have a Twitter
I'm like okay
let me get a sweater
made a new one
has like 50 followers I think I'm just
gonna delete it
I'm over it I think Twitter's irrelevant
at this point
it's like a it's literally a clout check
you know how you guys say Vigor check
it's a clout check
it's like
dude if you're vati video and you tweet
yo you're gonna get five thousand likes
it that means you're relevant
if you're iron pineapple
if you're Zully The Witch
three thousand three thousand retweets
minimum
yo what's go phosphorus thanks for
becoming a tarnish dude I appreciate
that thank you very much welcome
welcome to the agency good to have you
welcome thank you thank you
how come good promotion if you use and
Nah if I have my computer and it doesn't
remind us for everybody I like
huh
I'm just saying don't worry about it
you're good
you're golden
what's the game plan of this run I'm
just trying to kill I'm just trying to
kill Reichard
like I I can't even see I'm not kidding
I'm not kidding
this is hard
I killed godson Noble though which I
think is actually kind of impressive
for like barely any levels barely any
upgrades it's actually pretty good
okay let's not get grabbed this time
chat
let's not get grabbed
I'm just gonna roll a lot
it's not the direction we want to go
go
go
I'm literally just no
[ __ ] man
go
you don't even need to be able to see to
be right card
okay we got that let's go back this way
because there's no [ __ ]
Graces where I want to go
you fought God skin well I kind of have
him downloaded in my brain even if I'm
like slightly incoherent
I think the title says
um
I can still get him I can get him bro
what kind of run is this your mom
get [ __ ] LOL
it's overrun yeah
I'm usually much more uh articulate than
I am
reported
thanks bro
it's all good you died twice going the
wrong way
I haven't been going the wrong way I
wanted the somber 7 so when I get the
serpent Hunter we can upgrade it like a
[ __ ] ton
you know once we go to EG
needs an even number
I mean before I fight rycard I have to
take a shot so you're good
[Music]
don't kill me just don't
that snake is kind of obnoxious
kind of obnoxious
okay
let's go fight record
because we're ready now
[Music]
go go
almost died
continuing stream tomorrow uh no
[Laughter]
we can finish it tomorrow if you want
when I'm hung over like that might be
funny
because I'm probably gonna be there
tomorrow
sorry to say
all right what are the chances I beat
Reichard first try with a non-upgraded
serpent Hunter
what are the what what are the odds
zero percent
put it on me bro put it on me
I can beat this [ __ ] snake at any
point in time
[ __ ]
foreign
thank you
there's not even anything in that physic
and I took it
we we gotta play it we gotta play bro
like can you think of another content
creator that can beat Reichard stage one
completely incoherent
why why watch this chat watch
[Music]
thanks Brad bro I appreciate it but
oh very well
what
[Laughter]
enjoying your shopping
oh we will live
all the lyrical
hmm [ __ ] yeah
I want a first try Reichard just to
prove a point to myself
now
oh God together
I haven't heard that in a while
funny line whoops
I didn't think he'd double attacked
there that's my fault I can beat him
though we're good
we're good we're good we're good we're
good we're good
whoops yeah sorry art
that that entirely was my bad
might have been the the shot I took just
now might have been the shot
wait I was supposed to do the big attack
uh oh I died
we're good I do it now
got that didn't count right guys
oh update the counter my bad you're
you're right
I got this
we're actually in the double digits of
shots I did not think we'd get there
tonight but good job you guys good job
excellent excellent
what repair drivers [ __ ] off okay we're
good
I probably should update my drivers I'm
not gonna lie
it's been a while
60 100 of the time first try uh 60
that was my fault
this is such a cool boss can we all
agree on that
like this boss is one of my favorites in
the game
I [ __ ] love this boss
I know it's a gimmick but I don't care
I'm gonna get eaten
foreign
I love it I'm like kinky for that
not really though
oh run run run run
[ __ ] [ __ ] boy
press one in chat if I should learn the
eldering speedrun
I I think that's like the next thing I
want to do
I want to learn the speed run
I think speedrunning this game would
actually be super fun
we have a timer where the shots is and
everything [ __ ] yeah let's go
give me my zero runs
okay we're good
no I'm not doing any Zips it would be a
glitchless speedrun
literally
literally a glitchless speedrun
I don't really like glitches to be
honest
you're okay though depends
nice
good [ __ ]
I don't want to run from the skulls [ __ ]
bro I have to
Everybody Run
I got eaten
yeah
[Music]
that's kind of unlucky that he wanted to
do that right away
actually unlucky
actually unlucky actually unlucky
actually unlucky [ __ ]
what are the glitches
um there's some like glitches where you
can like fly across the entire map like
super quick I don't want to do that
I don't want to do any of that
no not per shot per death I would be
dead by now
we're just going before every Big Boss
maybe if I was good though
do you guys think I'm good at eldering
and I want you to be honest
Trey you just got me super [ __ ]
hungry
no
GG
do they'll shoot those two shots just
hit right now
it took a while for those
foreign
we're gonna go double LT here
get big damage
there's a lot of damage
we did not want what he just did
we need to run
like a lot
like it's basically a running simulator
at this point
[ __ ] man
I don't even know what's going on right
now
foreign
boss I'm not gonna lie
dead
I surrounded
I'm that good at the game I can't see
and I beat Reichard and there are
60 percent of players who did meet
Margaret Broly can you [ __ ] imagine
dude
60 percent of players who bought Elder
rang did not beat bro can you imagine
dude
can you imagine and I just beat
reichardt and I can't even coherently
see correctly
I'm making a point today
Point has been made
I look at chat and it's like okay now do
Melania
shut up
you know what you're doing
wait hold on
uh
yeah
hold everybody hold
calm calm yourselves real quick
five six seven one two three four
well I presume
is so [ __ ] cool
right
EG is so [ __ ] awesome
watch this we're about to run through
this game and you guys thought I was
done
I'm not
I'm not
I don't know why like when I'm
intoxicated I just like do this
weird
it's a [ __ ] wonder why I'm not
married yet right guys
it's literally [ __ ] incredible that
I'm not taken
can you believe that
that I'm single
[Laughter]
it's shocking
I don't die
Jake and metal nah she don't like me
she don't like me that way
I literally got friend zoned by metal
can you guys believe that
is that incredible yeah friend zone
all right it's the soul but it happened
oh God I'm dead okay I'm alive
Brent gets timed out so [ __ ] much
dude it's awesome
they don't even deserve you you're
afraid dude even people who don't
deserve me
have had a chance
and they haven't taken advantage in that
nuts
I went on a date last night though
though it was okay
it didn't blow me away though
I gotta get blown away
plus nine serpent Hunter whoa
okay where do we go now
free bread
can we beat dragon
tree Sentinel Dragon Tree Sentinel you
rock dude thank you
I'm trying to get married though
because I'm 28.
like the plan in my head was to be
married by 30 and I'm 20 almost 28. I'm
27 but I'm almost 28.
my plan in my head was to be married by
30.
which like that's okay if it doesn't
happen and then I want to live in Norway
by the time I'm 35 that's what I have in
my head
right Reaver I'm pretty good at the game
don't you think
gotta get blown away no no no I'm not
like
guys
this might be get me demonetized but sex
is so not important dude
it's so not important
it's so not important
if you like who you're around and you
like the company of the person that
you're in love with just stick with it
sex is not important
like sex is fun
but
you know it is what it is
look at this guy look at this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
this guy's dead as hell I tried to
Reichard is that
[Laughter]
okay that was my fault
[Laughter]
oh my god dude
whatever whatever bro it is what it is
pre-nut Clarity no it's not even that
man like once you get to my age it's
just like
it's fun it's cool to do but it's just
not the most important thing when you're
with your person
it's just not like
it's fun to do
when you're both in the mood but it
you gotta like what that person is
and a lot of people
don't do that
it's like wow they have such a nice ass
I'm so into them
yeah but like what if that ass doesn't
know how to cook or something
or like they're not very fun on a date
type of thing
like that nice ass don't look as good
now does it
it don't look as good
I can beat this guy I'm not worried
about it I can even be market like this
dude I can't even [ __ ] see holy [ __ ]
guys give me a percentage that this uh
stream is completely demonetized
completely
gone
this [ __ ] [ __ ] ass horse looking at
me like this
remind me to upgrade endurance
going how to cook Google it
what do you do when you're in daily life
and can't enjoy that ass if you're sick
or unemployed
guys I'm never gonna be unemployed at
this point I've done so many [ __ ]
things dude you have no idea you have no
idea how many of the things I've done
I've been a professional golfer I've
been a professional teacher in golf
um I've been a firefighter I went to
school for firefighting if you know
[Music]
um
I've been a graphic designer for a few
people
didn't go hard on that though
and then I've been a professional graph
designer
so
I've done so many things
just do what interests you in the moment
and just like [ __ ]
get into it
still got that firefighter bod you know
it
no so like by the way
I got depressed when I moved to Arizona
because I was trying to pursue
professional golf
I got hurt like [ __ ] right away which
is super annoying
I like literally got there went to the
driving range hit the ground and my hurt
like my wrist was just like I'm a [ __ ]
whatever
so I streamed a lot and I gained a [ __ ]
ton of weight like just so much like I I
literally had the McDonald's app
downloaded
oh imagine just so I could get deals so
I could go to McDonald's this was 30
years ago at this point
um I got to
225 pounds which is so much for being 5
10.
so much weight 225 pounds for 510 is
just a lot
um
you know over the last three years I've
been trying to lose weight
and now I weigh like 185 190 which I
would like to weigh 165.
but I've lost a lot of weight since then
510 Club nice let's go Reaper
avocado body
no
well actually I have a fat I have a fat
ass for anyone who's interested in that
uh but that's gonna stay I I will always
have a fat ass no matter how much weight
I'd lose
um
used to be a therapist
that's good I mean I I've had so many
careers it just doesn't matter like just
do what you want to do it's your life
like you live maximum 100 years or
whatever just do whatever the [ __ ] you
want to do like if you're if you're 15
or you're 30 or you're 45
just like do whatever you want to do man
you only live one life just [ __ ] go
like just do the thing right now I
really like Elden ring so I'm doing that
thing
um but I lost a lot of weight since 2019
which is when I lived in Arizona
and then you guys know what's crazy I
was like yes
I was depressed
and I'm in 2019 and I ate a lot of
McDonald's
and a lot of other fast food and I
gained a whole bunch of weight because I
was depresso mode
and I'm 225 pounds
by the way I lifted every day but I ate
like [ __ ] so what that equals is a lot
of muscle and a lot of weight
I didn't like left I didn't like feeling
that way so
I was Hefty
I was a big thick boy big ass big legs
big arms big body
I was fat
I wouldn't say I was fat like I didn't
have a gut sticking out but I was like I
I bulked as hard as you could I bought
this hard as you could
um dude I'm so drunk
I'm telling you guys too much but I
don't care
um didn't like feeling that heavy
so I uh I decided to lose the weight and
I said to myself I'm gonna lose a bunch
of weight I'm gonna hang out with a lot
more friends
and uh I'm gonna be a more active person
in the world and this was 2019 going
into 2020.
you get what I'm saying
about March 2020 covet hit and you
couldn't do [ __ ] all
[Laughter]
Colvin was like yeah all those plants
you had [ __ ] you you're not gonna be
able to do any of that [ __ ]
knows neither is anybody else so you're
gonna get you know
it's like okay let's pursue content
creation I was like really good at
valorant when the beta was out and then
like three weeks later I was irrelevant
um but got 20 000 subscribers on another
YouTube channel uh invalorant and then I
got big on Tick Tock with rocket League
because I gave one minute tip videos
because I have 7 000 [ __ ] hours in
rocket League
did that for a while and I'm like man I
ain't knew the game to come out eldering
comes out my whole world changes
and now we're drunk in 2023 what is life
man
what is life
[ __ ] crazy
why is this man not married
I don't know I am a catch and a half I
am so [ __ ] cool
foreign
I'm Not Dead
I used to be mad medicated for ADHD but
made my appetite worse so I felt hungry
yeah I got you
I wasn't reading chat at all I'm sorry
let me go back
used to be a therapist yeah it's crazy
me as 725 7 275.
I mean I'm not gonna lie man like
weights nothing
weights nothing man it's all here
guys life is right here
I'm telling you this is a 27 year old
old man
life is all right here
you got it you got Life by the balls and
you just gotta hit you gotta hit it
brain
life is literally all right here
you got it forehead brain
whatever's going on you can get through
it I don't care what it is you could
anything could have happened to you I
don't care how bad it is you could have
done it and you will get through that
[ __ ] I promise I've been through some
[ __ ] like maybe not as bad as some
people but like dude life sucks
and once you accept the fact that life
sucks dick life gets really [ __ ] cool
I promise
you're gonna be just fine
man
because life is pretty cool
life can be very interesting
foreign
bro
now
foreign
suck dick equals cool that's I don't
think I said that
I don't know
my brother's the same way for the same
reason what did Finn say now I'm curious
now I'm curious
where's Finn
you're a cool guy Jake Mrs AGT will come
along soon I know
you're right I appreciate you for saying
that
it it'll come along when I'm not looking
Miss AGT
he's like I would love to get married
I'm a very lovable person
[Music]
um I have a lot of love to give I think
I'm a good person I think
um whoever wants to be with me
will
um
have a you know if they want to be with
me too have a good life
along with me
um but just need that person to come
along that's all
gotta be patient
that's all
it'll be good
did you know the brain is the only thing
to ever name itself
the brain named itself is that true
it's kind of cool
uh oh
foreign
that hit me
pain and suffering
I can dodge that drunk
not that though
not that either
[Music]
I'm stuck in a rock in a hard place
I could have killed him
worse boss ball drunk uh this one
I'm getting all sentimental because I'm
trying to stall because I'm [ __ ]
trash at this boss
[Laughter]
suck dick equals cool when did I say
this stuff did I say this stuff I
actually agree life is full of [ __ ] but
if but it's kind of cool if you get
through the young years
uh dude for me
my 20s have sucked
[Music]
loved being like 10 years old to like
20. once I hit 20 life has been trash
but about 28 I've been pretty happy
27-28 I always enjoy the streams and
your authenticity cheers for you Jake
thank you Angel I'm happy you're here
man I'm always happy when you're here
when anybody's here thank you
um you guys can ask me anything I will
answer honestly I promise
and ever lie
no lines
oh
I'm okay
oh I didn't have a role
no that hit me okay I thought you'd Miss
to be honest that's my fault that's okay
man dude I need more stamina remind me
to upgrade salmon after this guy
this guy's easy peasy
I'm dead
no zichi thank you again angel
that gets you personal but do your meds
help I've struggled really a little
appetite for most of my life but I don't
I really like take medication
um you can talk to Zeta about that as
well because she used to be a therapist
um I took
I took some medication for depression
for a little while and I found not being
on it was a little bit better
that took experimentation though and I
don't regret taking it uh for a little
bit
whatever you let me check I'm not sure
sorry
I think my game crashed no it didn't uh
I am level
43.
am I actually at leandel's entrance at
43
holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ] really good to
be honest
like literally
no he's so these Sentinels are so
delayed oriented they wouldn't even be
hard if they didn't have a delayed thing
I can beat him though because I have a
plus nine weapon plus nine Weapon by the
way
65 bucks wait what did Angel say
he's just one of my favorite people
no no that's like uh 65 currency it was
uh 327.
USD
which I really appreciate thank you
every dollar counts chat it all goes
toward rent and [ __ ] like that
like if you if you guys want me to keep
doing content full time
super chats becoming members that's like
one of the biggest things you can do and
I appreciate you thank you
and then watching videos obviously but
that that that's like a given you guys
will do that whenever
okay let me focus on this guy I got it
thank you
his hitbox is so [ __ ] weird look at
that
I'm straight feed him and he hits me
have you been trying to gain weight Zeta
a lot of people try to gain weight I've
been trying to lose weight I'm still on
a journey because I'm like 185 right now
Chad and I would like to be 165 by the
end of the year that's my goal
the place I'm moving into has a [ __ ]
awesome gym so I'm I'm really excited
for that now
let me heal
couldn't heal that that time that was a
bad time to heal
please
no why that can I roll
man dude
okay man
crazy man
yeah I think these nights are due to
heads as well I need more stamina
watch if I go get the uh how close am I
to something like that
if I go get the stamina I'm gonna go get
the stamina talisman
I probably can't get it [ __ ] we'll see
I'm gonna go get it
hold everybody hold
it's fine we're fine
do you have a favorite non-major boss
let me think let me think
does it have to be a boss or can it be a
normal enemy
you have a favorite sandwich uh I'm a
big fan of ham ham sandwich
not huge on Turkey
I like uh or chicken I like ham though
I should do that too Reed any
hmm
foreign
I'm thinking
um
favorite enemy outside of a major boss
I mean are godskin nobles not considered
major bosses I don't think they are are
they
but I'm big on ham Logan
um
I would say like the godskins are super
[ __ ] cool
and I I don't know if they're considered
major bosses
wow
can I get a stagger Maybe
there we go
our godskin considered uh you might
count that okay let me think a bit like
more
hmm
like even lesser than that because that
I would consider uh godskins to be a
major boss
[Music]
it's hard
it's a major boss
oh I went right past the Talisman we
wanted didn't I I was just I was just
going
um
I was thinking
this is
I don't know I don't know
godskins are minor bosses don't even
give remembrances
yeah I mean anything that gives
a remembrance is definitely a major boss
is getting a boss yeah I I consider him
I consider Gideon a main character
um because I think he's the most evil
person in the Lance between personally
even more so than like America the
greater will I think Gideon's even worse
than all of them I'm I'm not kidding
I think America and like radagon and all
those people had intentions and Gideon
was like had the worst in intentions
personally [ __ ]
okay
where can I get us a key
dude my phone's been dead for like an
hour don't even [ __ ] care
like you guys think any girls are
messaging me probably not
they should be in this stream
it should be
does the um
there's a merchant up here have one
didn't know I had that
Knight's Cavalry is actually pretty cool
that's a good answer
nice Calvary is a really good answer for
a non-major boss
that's a good answer
not with that attitude sorry
you don't
the key
um let me go back at it
how many non-members are in the Stream
thousands
literally a thousand no cap
okay
we went all that way for nothing Chad
it's sad it's sad I'm a little sad it is
what it is
imagine getting more than zero messages
from girls couldn't be me
right [ __ ] man
I'm good with it dude like
also
do you guys agree that dating is kind of
weird now
I used I used to find dating like really
easy like early early college
you know seven eight years ago now
really easy
like they you know they'd want to go on
dates
all the time
and now it's like
it has to be
like if you want to go and have a hookup
you go to a bar
but if you want to have a major
relationship which is what I'm looking
for you have to you have to do it
through a dating app I don't know how
you meet a girl who's not like has
intentions of only a hookup
through
like just going to a bar
that's the only experience I've had
going out like a normal a norm a normie
a normie
is like all they want to do is hook up
and that's it
man you're [ __ ] fast
nice [ __ ]
foreign
I played uh bloodborne and DS3 on the
channel you should go check out those
streams they're in a playlist song of
Their Own
there we had like some really fun
playthroughs
I had a great time playing those games
on stream
dude [ __ ] man he's so fast
that's crazy I thought I dodged that
pretty well
nice
jump at me
dead as hell
that is hail and they give you 100K for
that are you kidding me
that's a lot
damn
I wasn't reading Chad I'm sorry
yeah I had the clean kill there that was
clean that was good
crucibles are good I would say Knights
Calvary are the most uh interesting to
me to be honest that's Calvary for sure
I got deployed
yeah that's that's gotta be [ __ ]
crazy man I feel you there
stamina thank you
let's get a 20 on that
um vigor's pretty important let's get
that 27 maybe one more in string let's
go big thank you guys
stamina super important at this point
also like Samurai's armor why would I
change it it looks good and it's good
like in general
literally a hair on my head in my face
crazy
12K
M we're good
we got everything we need right now to
just like Farm like just go [ __ ]
crazy because we can kill Godfrey really
easy
I wish you could jump off this Edge over
here but you can't anymore
all right here comes Melina guys to like
[ __ ] tell us that oh I don't need you
anymore but in about 10 minutes I'm
gonna need you again
[Music]
my for bringing me here and shedding
that's not what's happening
bye
Yahoo
y'all know it
how many other tarnish do you think
she's talking to
a lot
like she's got like 14 million matches
on Tinder about
like 14 mil no joke
however many players have played
eleanoring
it's not real Maiden nah but you know
she's pretty [ __ ] good for what she
does
pretty [ __ ] pretty good pretty good
at what she does
she's an empirion yes she is
here's an appearing
okay Killian nurture Avatar real quick
easy peasy 11 squeezy
easy peasy lemon squeezy Newman Rune
acquired
that hurt
I did not expect to be here but I am
here so here I am
kind of unfair not gonna lie
can I get out of here please
no okay
nice you [ __ ]
um Melina I think is in a fragment of
Queen America herself or is the daughter
of Queen America one of the demigods
that died
um
so she could have been an empirion yes
yes
okay are you guys saying next shot is
morgot can we agree on that
not god-free but morgot can we can we
agree on that
because they're right next to each other
like cut me some slack man America's
third personality
I mean it makes sense like think think
of the shattering
a lot of fragments went everywhere I
don't think it's a far stretch to say
that Melina is like
a fragment of Melinda's will
of what she she wanted to happen
Jay seems to be sobering up I'm not I
can't see still I'm just kind of going
along because this is like muscle memory
no joke this is muscle memory
I'm that good
do you have a favorite build kind of
what I'm doing right now is my favorite
I would say like
um whatever a build would be best for
which would be an uh mind intelligence
strength
Vigor would be uh ruins great sword
that's my favorite build
but I know serpent Hunters really
[ __ ] good
you're not slurring was I earlier
no
I was not
I can beat Godfrey like this no prob
I was literally the best earlier
how would I have gotten this far without
being the best
tell me that
it's not a thing
foreign yeah
yeah angel
I I am I believe that radagon in America
were always the same person and radagon
came to be
while America was the queen
I don't think radagon was his own person
at any point
unless they split like they he came from
America and he was always
part of her
that that's what I think
all right Godfrey
I need to get that Turtle Talisman ASAP
Rocky
look at me go chat
look at me look at me go
foreign
do I have a Talisman equipped
and I'm at morga
goddamn
yeah
I'm killing it killing it
worst common enemy for you personally
it's the Hawks it's the birds
birds are the worst
personally
although we have 10 more Vigor than the
entire [ __ ] challenge that we did
last week
dogs nah not worse than birds for me
personally
wait I want to go this way I want to go
the other way
can we beat morgot like this
we're gonna have to take a shot if I
want to keep going man I was gonna stop
after Reichard but here we are we're
still going dude we're still killing it
dude Rune bears are actually [ __ ]
crazy strong
Chad would you rather fight five Rune
Bears or Millennia stage one
I think I'd rather fight Melania at this
point because I'm like a god at her now
like I would
well honest
in search of the Eldon ring
Jesus
he's bad at the game to be honest
well I'm dead
oh wait I'm fine
that's like an unfair grab
unfair
phase one maladia yeah I'd rather fight
her there
got all right I get I get to use
Millennia though
I do or sorry melna
I get to use Melina
here we go look how much there is left
laughs
caps on
that was the last shot we got
that was the last one [ __ ] dude
yep
bottles empty
from the bottle yeah the whiskey the the
shot glass has not been used for a while
not been used
okay morgant let's go
skip to irrelevant let's go
so bright out here
whoops forgot to [ __ ] roll dude
Melina
hello
goddess movement is [ __ ] cool
foreign
that was bad
that's sad
foreign
[Music]
foreign
what
I never thought that ends to me damn
I thought I'd get like halfway down my
health bar that insted me dude damn bro
that was good though that's good
I never thought that ends to me
did The Allman Works roll no legs
last boss for today I don't know
I
don't
know
I'm here
look at me go
six five five forty five and five forty
hi Mark or grit hi Margaret
that was a little unfair
kind of crazy aren't you
oh I didn't summon Melina that's not
good
I forgot
whoops
because Melina is very helpful
I tried to roll did uh not time it
correctly
foreign
foreign
oh come on
foreign
that's Bad News Bears
oh Chad look at this health I went for
it dude and he just went
he went he went
what are we fighting Mar Moore got at
level 59
11 shots in
and I almost killed him
am I really good at this game
y'all saw it right like this [ __ ]
there's nothing in there
that's it
it's gone
that's all we got that's all the alcohol
we currently have
and I almost killed morgot and I didn't
summon Melina again like a dumb [ __ ]
I think I can kill him like this
he's just kind of weird you know
it's kind of a weirdo
foreign
Jesus man
foreign
[Music]
that shouldn't have hit me it was all
over him that time
the right part in this I rolled twice
are you serious
oh
very
like dude my confidence level in this
game is gonna go to like a billion if I
can beat more guy like this
he he just did like actually really
unlucky movement there
how's our Vigor more than what we had
before we also are using no talismans
like I don't have a good Talisman I'm
just here
foreign
okay Melina
Melina there we go
that was a good try I feel like I'm
doing really good against morgot where I
can't see
like I'm just like literally reacting to
him
dagger is so [ __ ] annoying
that was my fault
weird movement
kill him melanon murder him
he has more Health if I use Melina
though
just saying my my phone's been dead for
like an hour and a half
how many feet picks do you think I have
you play this for 5 000 hours try 715
close to that
uh
cinnamon no I didn't use melona
I keep forgetting about Mel and a man my
brain my brain is [ __ ]
it's fine
I rolled man what the [ __ ] dude
foreign
dude more God's movement is [ __ ]
weird
[ __ ] weird man
it's kind of an idiot
oh dude
oh dude
maybe she's not that important
she's important
[ __ ] I had I hit the drunk part where
I'm tired [ __ ] man
I know I can beat the game like this
like literally at the state I'm at I
could beat the game
like what is that [ __ ] movement dude
he has a follow-up to that really
yeah
look at that
like when do you attack him I don't know
I don't know
[Music]
he summons the erdry spear yep
ow
oh that last shot hit hard right now
chat like 15 minutes later
let's get another water bottle
we'll be okay
foreign
I can't see
why did that shot hit like literally 15
minutes later
[Music]
foreign
at all
get a melna
murder kill
Ed
foreign
I felt like I was definitely far enough
away there
Pokemon Melina
shall not be forgiven
foreign
damn that hurt okay
I can do this
not like that though
no one is dead
she's gonna give us life though
foreign
ow
Run
come over here
what was that
what hit me
what hit me man
I'm like too focused right now
I'm literally too focused
okay what's the boat at in the member
only Discord where did I put that at
voting obviously
um okay so I asked would you rather have
private member channels in the main
Discord
or stick with the members only Discord
and they voted 14-3
just have private channels in the main
Discord
surprise me
but sounds good
now I can focus on one
remember physic
I don't I don't have anything in my
physique
and we've almost killed them twice
somehow
I'm not gonna use Melina I'm actively
telling you I'm not using Melina here
here we go
and I can't see
currently can't see
more guy kill watch
Bad start
really bad start
out
how did that [ __ ] hit me what that's
weird actually like actual that one too
dude all those hits were weird
all of those hits were weird man
literally all of them
uh okay you need Melina I need you
think about that
good night John I I'm feeling bet on
pretty soon too I I feel I will feel
good about myself if I beat Margaret
yeah
like this
literally half a bottle of tequila or
fire Fireball
[Music]
did I summon melna
I don't know
yeah she's right there
right yeah
foreign
she was worthless at that point like
what
I swear morghat is always harder when
you've had 11 shots
dude morgot might be easier when you've
had 11 shots just because of his weird
ass [ __ ] delayed ass movement think
about it like
if I were sober I'd be reacting to his
normal movement
but he delays like a [ __ ] in
this fight
so
this might be better
I'm alive for six hours that's kind of
[ __ ] insane actually
break the throne [ __ ] him
foreign
foreign
nice
very good
very good chat
this looks very promising right here if
I don't throw
very very promising
[ __ ]
foreign
get your get your ass over here
let it be known that AGT Jake beat more
got 11 shots into a six hour live stream
let it be known
let it be known I did it
damn bro
damn bro
look
look
but but
all right chat six hours of being
[ __ ] drunk sounds good to me
and beating more God that's pretty good
man that's pretty good
listen
I appreciate every single one of you
from the bottom of my heart thank you
for all the support recently
I'd need to go to bed and get a water
bottle before I do laughs
remind me to plug in my phone too
about another six nah
nah they could be a fun stream like
let's finish the
let's finish the drunk stream
that'll be a fun stream one day probably
tomorrow
um guys
thank you
for a Wonderful Life and a wonderful
year
last year and this year
I will see you all soon
thank you very much
um I'm gonna be done because I probably
should be right
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you all
um I'm gonna go to bed
I love you
and I will see you all soon
peace and love
I hope you had fun tonight I did
hahaha
all right good night guys
thank you I'm gonna get some good sleep
very good sleep
up worth the gifts yes thank you all
right good night everybody I will see
you um I'll try and maybe do a hand a
hungover stream tomorrow morning if I
feel like streaming tomorrow morning
we'll be on and we will literally
continue this run no joke so
they'll actually be funny all right
good night
peace and love
and uh I'll give you a I'll give you a
cuddle for melna all right
guys good night thanks for everything
appreciate you bye-bye bye bye bye
bye
bye